THIS IS THE MEETING OF US UP
FIVE PUBLIC SAFETY A BUDGET
MEETING. AND.
.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO HAVE THOSE
WHO ARE HERE TODAY I UNDERSTAND
THAT.
.
ON SOME OF THEM MAY BE ASSN WE
GENERAL BACK TO TRY TO WAIT IN
AND.
WE CAN BEGIN THE INFORMATIONAL
PIECE WHEN HE GETS HERE WE'LL.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY AND AND
THE DEPARTMENT DOES SECRETARY A
SECRETARY KERN IN THIS YEAR HE'S
GOING TO GIVE US AN OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF MEANWHILE
HAVE THE POPULATION OVERVIEW
AFTERWARDS.
SO WILL INVITE UP TO THE A.
DESTINED TO SPEAK WITH US ON A
SECRETARY KERN.
WHO'S WITH THE DICK.
CDC ARE SO.
WELCOME.
LET'S THERE WERE A WILL CALL THE
LAUGHTER.
WITH WITH WITH THE RIVER.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY EXPAND CHAIR
MEMBERS
NOW I.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTION.
FRANTICALLY SHE
CALVET.
VERY BRIEFLY I'M OVERVIEW ABOUT
PROGRESS.
WE MET LAST YEAR.
CDC OUR HAS CONTINUE MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THAT
PROGRESS IN ALL ASPECTS OF HOW
WE INCARCERATE IN THE STATE.
FROM WE HAVE PROGRAMS TO GANG
MANAGEMENT SIGNING THEM EXCEPT
FOR MEDI CAL TO EMIT EMPLOYMENT.
RE ENTRY TO IMPLEMENTING STAFF
TRAINING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
HEALTH CARE TO IMPROVEMENTS IN
OUR DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
CARE.
INCREMENTAL PROGRESS IN
IMPERFECT SYSTEM.
I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU THAT
PROP FIFTY SEVEN WAS IMPLEMENTED
JUST SEVEN MONTHS AGO HISTORICAL
REFORM THAT REALLY CHANGED HOW
WE INCARCERATE IN THE STATE.
INCENTIVIZE INMATES TO
PARTICIPATE IN REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND EARN THEIR WAY TOO
EARLY RELEASE IT PROVIDES HOPE
TO THE SYSTEM.
THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD NO HOPE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTIES THE AVERAGE
SENTENCE WAS AROUND.
TWENTY FIVE MONTHS TODAY IT'S
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS JUST
UNDER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO THE PENDULUM HAS SWUNG ON
OUR.
POPULATION SIGNIFICANTLY PROP
FIFTY SEVEN GIVES US A WAY TO
GET OUT OF THAT PROBLEM I'LL
TALK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT THAT. A
IN THE SECOND THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN PROJECT A POP IS ABOUT
A HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED. AND THAT'S TWENTY
NINE HUNDRED BELOW CURRENT YEAR
IN THE FOR ALL POPULATION IS
GOING TO GROW TO FORTY NINE
EIGHT HUNDRED ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED MORE. THOSE THOSE
EFFORTS THAT REDUCTION IN PRISON
POPULATION CAN BE DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO PROP FIFTY
SEVEN.
OF THE DEPARTMENT MADE HER
HERCULEAN EFFORT TO TRY TO
IMPLEMENT SO FAST THESE OF THIS
CHANGE IN OUR SYSTEM YOU CAN
GOING TO ANY OF OUR PRISONS
TODAY AND SEE INMATES. I'M
PARTICIPATING IN PROGRAM ARMY OF
VOLUNTEERS COMING AND.
HOME A REAL CHANGE IN HOW WE
INCARCERATE IN THIS STATE.
HOME I I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE POPULAR DE BUDGET ITEMS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO.
HERE TODAY A ONE OF THEM.
IS VERY CONCERNING TO ME AND
THAT'S THE LA OWES
RECOMMENDATION TO CLOSE CRC. AND
TO KEEP WHEN OUT A STATE
PROGRAM.
IN ARIZONA WHO WHAT IT HAD THE
EFFECT OF DOING IS INFLAMING
MICE MY STAFF AT CRC.
IT ALSO HAD OF THE. UNKNOWN
IMPACT OF IN GREEN CCPOA WITHOUT
NOTICE AND JUST SIMPLY A BAD
RECOMMENDATION BY THE BUT BY THE
LA NO.
THE THREE JUDGE PANEL WAS VERY
CLEAR AND AS YOU ALL KNOW WE ARE
IN GREAT POPULATION CAP OF A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE.
THAT THE COURTS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR ABOUT HOW THE STATE
PROGRAMS
IT SAID THAT IT'S NOT IS. A
DURABLE OR DESIRABLE SOLUTION IT
WAS SENT THOUSANDS OF INMATES.
WAY THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY
FROM FAMILY SUPPORT IT WILL
SPEND HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE SPENT ON
LANGUAGE LONG LASTING REFORM.
THE COURT ORDERED US TO THAT WE
COULD NOT INCREASE THE OUT OF
STATE POPULATION BY MORE THAN
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED. AND IT SAID
TO EXPLORE WAYS TO GET OUT OF
COSTA THE SAME THING THAT THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE THIS BODY. I'M
ASKED US TO DO LAST YEAR SO IN
THIS BUDGET WE PROPOSE TAKING
DOWN ARE AT THE STATE PROGRAMS.
AND SPELL FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
INMATES TODAY.
WILL BRING DOWN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED IN MISSISSIPPI BY JUNE
OF EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED IN THE FALL OF NINETEEN.
BUT TO THE CHALLENGES OF OUR
POPULATION CONTINUE.
WITH THE LEGAL CHALLENGES PROP
FIFTY SEVEN IS GOING TO THE
REGULATIONS WILL BE FILED ON
MARCH TWENTIETH IT'S BEEN A LONG
ROAD TO GET THOSE REGULATIONS
FORTY ONE THOUSAND PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
WHICH WOULD WITH WHICH WE HAVE
TO RESPOND TO AND WE WILL
RESPOND IN TIME ON MARCH
TWENTIETH OF THOSE REGULATIONS
WILL BE FATHER WE WILL HAVE THE
OPERATION OF LAW ON PROP FIFTY
SEVEN.
BUT THERE IS A NUMBER OF OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT DEPARTMENTS
FACING IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE UP
TO OUR PROPOSITION.
THOSE LEGAL CHALLENGES INCLUDED
SUCH THINGS AS A SECULAR
SUPERIOR COURT ON SEX OFFENDERS
WHEN CLEARLY THE BALLOT MEASURE
IN THE GOVERNOR INTENDED TO
EXCLUDE SEX OFFENDERS. SO THAT
LOWER COURT DECISION WILL BE
APPEALED.
TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WAS SOLD TO THE VOTERS
THAT SEX OFFENDERS WOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED. ADDITIONALLY THERE'S.
FILINGS IN THE SUPREME COURT A
RELATED ALLOWING THIRD STRIKERS
IN TO OUR.
A NONVIOLENT FOR ALL PROCESS
THIRD STRIKERS ALL INDETERMINATE
SENTENCE INMATES WERE NEVER
INTENDED TO BE INCLUDED IN OUR
NONVIOLENT PAROLE PROCESS WE
WILL APPEAL THAT TO THE HIGHEST
COURT.
DIDN'T SO THAT THE OTHER
CHALLENGE I THINK THAT'S.
BEFORE SYSTEM REDUCING CRIME
KEEPING CALIFORNIA SAFE ACT
IT'S GETTING SIGNATURES BUT IT
ON YOU KNOW I THINK THE POORLY
WRITTEN INITIATIVE DOES A NUMBER
OF THINGS. THAT CREATES AB.
INSTABILITY IN OUR POPULATION
INVECTIVE THAT MEASURE IF THAT
PROPOSITION IS ULTIMATELY PASSED
IT WILL WIPE OUT ALL OF THE
SAVINGS FOR PROP FIFTY SEVEN
THAT. ALMOST ALL OF THE SAVINGS
THAT WE PROJECT FOR.
PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
JUNE SO THE.
LA JOH IN G. O. F. PRELIMINARY
ANALYSIS OF THAT INITIATIVE SAID
IT WOULD IMPACT ABOUT A THOUSAND
INMATES AND COST TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. TO GET
DEEPER ANALYSIS A REAL LEGAL
THEORY IS THAT IT WILL IMPACT
NINE UP TO NINE THOUSAND INMATES
AND COST TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MORE TOWARDS THE HUNDRED
OF.
MILLION DOLLARS ACTUALLY NAY
AND IT WILL AGAIN REDUCE ALL OF
THE SAVINGS THAT WE WORK SO HARD
TO.
OBTAIN SO FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS TO THINK THAT WE COULD
CLOSE CRC.
IT'S JUST.
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT CRC.
IS.
SYSTEM THE STAFF AT THAT SYSTEM
AT AT THAT PRISON AND WORK VERY
HARD TO KEEP THAT I'M VERY OLD
PRISON TOGETHER. BUT OUR
POPULATION JUST DOES NOT ALLOW
US TO CLOSE ICRC AT THIS POINT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO TURN TO.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE MOST OF OUR
BUDGET REQUESTS ARE A LOT OF OUR
BUDGET REQUESTS IS RELATED TO
JUST BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
RANGE THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR WE
HAVE.
HAD TERRIBLE.
FLOODING AND.
ROOF DAMAGE ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
AND SO THE BUDGET REQUEST THAT
YOU THAT YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT.
TODAY IN AND IN FUTURE SESSIONS
IS RELATED TO US TRYING TO GET A
HOLD OF THEM FIXING THE ROADS
AND PROVIDE AN ENVIRONMENT.
TO THAT I HAVE ATTACHMENTS FOR
YOU ATTACHED A LETTER FROM THE.
PRISON LAW OFFICE THAT TOOK ON
SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THOSE PICTURES WHICH YOU WILL
SEE IS A MADE SLEEPING WITH
PLASTIC BAGS OVER THE. LIGHTING
FIXTURES
KEEP THE WATER OFF THEIR BED
THAT'S IN IN TALL A TOLERABLE
SITUATION IN MY MIND AND IT'S
JUST.
NOT PROVIDING A BASIC HUMAN
REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE A LIVABLE
ENVIRONMENT SO THOSE UNADDRESSED
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES ARMS WILL
KICK NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. ARM
IN WALL THIS BUDGET REQUEST
DOESN'T SOLVE ALL OF OUR
PROBLEMS THE INVESTMENT IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE REQUIRED
IN FUTURE BUDGETS.
THE ONE TIME COSTS THAT YOU WILL
HEAR ABOUT IS RELATED TO FIRST
RESPONDER.
FIRST RESPONDER KIND OF
SERVICES SO TO BE ROPES AND
RADIO SYSTEM IN HEALTH CARE
VEHICLE SO THAT WE COULD TAKE
OUR. OUR INMATES.
TO THEIR MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS
AND SUCH.
ANOTHER BIG PART OF OUR REFORM
IS IN MADE EMPLOYMENT.
I THINK A VERY COMMON SENSE.
POINTS AND I'VE HEARD IT FROM
AND OUR OUR PRIVATE DISCUSSIONS
IS THAT A LIVABLE WAGE IS KEY TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM. UMP SO WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ANY TO GET
JUSTICE INVOLVED.
FOLKS AS INTO THE STATEWIDE
EMPLOYMENT PLAN INCREASED
COORDINATION WITH THE TRAITS
IMPACT THE PRISON INDUSTRY
AUTHORITY.
AYE IS PROVIDING TOOLS AND
UNION DUES FOR MEMBERS ONCE THEY
COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAM SO THAT
WHEN AN OFFENDER GETS OUT THAT
CAN GO TO THE UNION ALL HAVE A.
A LIFETIME. EMPLOYMENT.
COULDN'T SEWING INCREASED TRADE
APPRENTICESHIPS DIRECT KIND OF
INMATES INTO THE STATE'S SOBEL
SERVICE JOBS WE'RE ACTUALLY
HAVING INMATES APPLYING WHILE
THEY'RE IN PRISON TO GO WORK FOR
CALTRANS WOULD UGS.
ALL.
ALT KEY TO.
CREATING THE ENVIRONMENT THAT I
THINK PROP FIFTY SEVEN HAS HAS
GIVEN US TO CHANGE HOW WE
INCARCERATE IN THE STATE ONE OF
OUR BUDGET PROPOSALS.
INVOLVES. TAKING A PAROLE
PAROLE  CAMP IS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A ABOUT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
INMATES HAVE FIGHT FIRES ACROSS
OUR SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW WHO WROTE
CONVECTIVE LOST A COUPLE OF
THOSE FIREFIGHTERS.
AS THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING THE
DANGEROUS WORK THAT THEY DO.
VALLEY ALWAYS RECOMMENDED.
AGAINST THAT PROPOSAL AND THAT
IS THE ESSENCE OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TRYING TO CREATE IN
THIS IS SIMPLY THAT.
OFFENDERS THAT SPEND THEIR LIFE
IN OUR HOME
AS SPEND THEIR CAR SERRATION ARE
WORKING IN OUR FIRE CAMPS IN
GETTING THAT SKILLS. ON YOU WANT
TO GOING TO THE FIRE TRADE WHEN
THEY'RE DONE.
AND IT JUST MAKES SENSE TO TRY
TO PROVIDE A VEHICLE IN WHILE
THAT THE ALLEY ALWAYS SUGGESTED
THAT IT'S BECAUSE IT WON'T
REDUCE RECIDIVISM I THINK THAT
UNDERMINES WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IN OUR SYSTEM. OF TRYING TO
PROVIDE AVENUES FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE MEANINGFUL
WORK.
.
SO I I I JUST SAY THAT I THINK
THAT THAT THE REJECTION OF THE
FIRE CAMPUS AND OTHER BAD
RECOMMENDATION BY THE LA NO.
IN OTHER PROPOSALS TO TAKE
SEVENTY SIX YOU.
IN HOUSE IN OUR G. DJJ FACILITY
THAT WERE CONVICTED IN ADULT
COURT COMMITTED CRIMES BEFORE
THEY'RE EIGHTEEN BERNIE BIRTHDAY
WHERE ADJUDICATED BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONE.
INCOMPLETE THEIR SENTENCE BEFORE
THEIR TWENTY FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
ADULT PRISONS EAT UP YOUNGER
OFFENDERS IN SO KEEPING
OFFENDERS IN DJJ I.
OF FOR A GREATER PEER TIME
BETTER PROGRAMMING WITHIN THE IT
WITHIN THAT. YOU REALLY REFORM
SYSTEM IS JUST COMMON SENSE
AND BUTTON IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK THAT IS.
IN ESSENCE OF AGAIN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TRYING TO DO WITH
PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
SO IN CONCLUSION WHAT I'D LIKE
TO SAY IS THAT WE ARE SYSTEM ON
THE MOVE WE'RE CHANGING THEM.
WE'RE CHANGING THE SYSTEM FOR
STAFF AND INMATES WERE TRYING TO
DO SMARTCARD SERRATION WHERE
NATIONWIDE LEADER IN CORRECTIONS
THAT I THINK YOU CAN BE PROUD
OF.
IN I DON'T WANT YOU TO JUST
BELIEVE ME I HOPED SHE WOULD
TALK TO OUR MARK CRITICS TO.
INMATES THERE ADVOCATES I'M AND
OTHERS INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN IN OUR STATE I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU.
ON TO SUSTAIN THIS PROGRESS
GOING FORWARD AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO TRY TO INCIDENT
AS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WINNER CALDERON ON
THAT DAY I THINK EVERYONE IS
HERE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WEBER HERE.
JONES SAWYER HERE. LACKEY HERE
MULLIN DANCE.
STONE. TING.
THANK YOU.
OF WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE WITH US
OUR BUDGET YEAR WITH SITTING
AND.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ATTAIN WHO'S HERE
WITH US ALSO TODAY.
ANY QUESTIONS YES.
STONE.
THANK YOU IT.
UNDERSTAND YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND
AND YOUR REACTION TO THE
RECOMMENDATION TO CLOSE THE
FACILITY.
IT IN THIS WAY BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW WAS
WHAT WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR
CLOSING FACILITIES.
WE'RE SEEING REDUCTION IN
INMATES WERE SINGLE REDUCTION IN
CRIME ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE COMING OUT OF AN AREA
WHERE WE HAD STARTED SENDING
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE INTO
PRISONS AND. REALIZING WHAT.
AND IMPACT THAT HAS ON
CALIFORNIA WOULD A MISTAKE THAT
THAT ULTIMATELY WAS SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE THE BENEFIT OF THE
REFORMER KNOCK AND SEE THE
BENEFIT. OF THE COST SAVINGS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
UNTIL WE REALLY START TO CLOSE
SOME OF THE FACILITIES THAT WERE
BUILT.
IN THAT FRENZY TO TO BUILD
PRISONS AND MAYBE SOME OLDER
ONES I COMPLETELY AGREE WE CAN'T
BE SENDING PRISONERS OUT OF
STATE.
WE NEED TO KEEP THEM HERE AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO START DOING THAT
WE NEED TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS YOUR STAFF THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING THERE AND. DIED.
NOT DO IT WITHOUT A SENSITIVITY
TO WHAT THAT WORKFORCE IS IT AND
WHO THEY'RE BRINGING. WHICH
MEANS THERE NEEDS TO BE A PLAYER
THERE NEEDS TO BE A THOUGHT OF
WHERE WE WANT TO GO OVER TIME.
AND HOW WE GET THERE AND SO IF
WE CAN.
HAVE IF WE WILL HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT AND I KNOW
YOU COME IN WITH REQUESTS FOR
FACILITIES AND.
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR NOT
HAVING TO PUT THE PLASTIC OVER
THE LAMP SHADES TO TO PROTECT
THEIR BEDS FROM THE WATER THERE
A LOT OF CRUMBLING FACILITIES
BUT WE GET CAUGHT UP IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WHEN. THERE IS THIS
NOTION OF WE WE HAVE TO FIX OUR
FACILITIES THE FEAR IS THAT
WE'RE JUST CREATING MORE BATS
WERE
S. BUILDING LARGER FACILITIES.
AND NOT BUILDING THEM IN WAYS
THAT ARE CONDUCIVE TO THE
REHABILITATION MODEL THAT.
I NO WORK WE'RE HEADING INTO SO
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT HOW DO WE
REALLY LOOK AT THE WHOLE SYSTEM
WHAT THE CAPACITY IS WHERE WE
WANT TO GO. AND START LOOKING AT
WHAT FACILITIES WE WE CAN START
TO MOVE AWAY FROM.
I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY FAIR
QUESTION AND PLEASE DON'T TAKE
FROM MY COMMENTS THAT I DON'T
THINK AT SOME POINT. THAT WE DO
NEED TO CLOSE.
PRISONS.
PROP FIFTY SEVEN WILL DO THAT
LET ME SAY THIS TO YOU THAT IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHO'S SEVEN MONTHS AGO OR SO.
ARE WE WERE THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE INMATES UNDER THE
FEDERAL CAP
THAT THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
INMATES IS IS TRULY A BAD
WEEKEND IN OUR WORLD. BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONTROL OF HOW
THE COUNTY SAN INMATES TO US
THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE. IT
WAS A LOT OF SLEEPLESS NIGHTS TO
THAT PERIOD WHEN WE GO OVER THAT
CAP WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT FEDERAL
COURT. OF TO A COMPLIANCE
OFFICER RELEASES OFFENDERS
THAT IS ONE OF THE ESSENCE OF
WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO STOP THAT'S
WHAT. PROP FIFTY SEVEN DID.
IF IF IT WEREN'T FOR PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WE WOULD BE OVER THE CAP
FACING COURT. BATTLE RELEASES
TODAY.
THAT THAT IS THE FACT OF THE
MATTER WE.
NEEDED PROP FIFTY SEVEN TO WORK.
I THINK THAT THE INSTABILITY OF
THE POPULATION IN INITIATIVE
THAT IS YOU KNOW IS GETTING
SIGNATURES TODAY THAT'S GONNA
WIPE OUT OUR.
SAVINGS PUTS US IN THIS
TERRIBLE SITUATION AND AS A
SECRETARY WHAT I WOULD SAY TO
YOU.
AND YOU KNOW AND TALKING TO THE
GOVERNOR DIRECTLY WE DO NOT WANT
ITS NOT GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
TO RELEASE VENDORS BY THE
COURTS.
WHAT FIFTY SEVEN DID IS IT
CHANGED THAT INSTEAD OF THE
COURTS JUST RELEASING
INDISCRIMINATELY OFFENDERS
OFFENDERS THAT ARE GOING TO
SCHOOLS THAT ARE GOING INTO A
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THEY CAN
EARN THEIR WAY OUT THAT IS A
MUCH BETTER WAY TO DO IT? AND I
ALSO SAY TO YOU FOR. THIRTY FIVE
YEARS I WORKED IN THE APARTMENT
WAS A TWO HUNDRED PERCENT
OVERCROWDING EVERY SPACE IN THE
PRISON WAS.
HUMAN DENSITY JAMS AND DAY ROOMS
AND WE GOT WHAT WE SET OUT WE
GOT A VIOLENCE WE GOT WORSE
CRIMINAL WHEN WE GOT OUT.
I TO YOUR POINT ABOUT HAVING A
PLAN I THINK THAT THAT WE HAVE
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF THIS
POPULATION.
POSSIBILITIES LOOKING IN THE
FUTURE I THINK THE LA DOES
RECOMMENDATION IS JUST WAY PRO
PREMATURE NOTWITHSTANDING THE
INSENSITIVITY TO MY STAFF IT AT.
TO PRISON OR THE UNION.
BUT IT DOES NEED TO BE A PLAN
WE DO NEED TO HAVE A DISCUSSION.
HOME AS THE POPULATION IS.
REDUCED.
HOW HOW DO WE GO ABOUT CLOSING
THE PRISON I THINK IT'S OF
ABSOLUTE FAIR CONVERSATION I
JUST THINK? I'M IN THIS BUDGET
AT THIS TIME IT'S.
JUST NOT DO MY UNDERSTANDING
SENSITIVITY TO THIS AND AND.
MAYOR MADE OUT BE PREMATURE BUT.
GETTING OUT AHEAD OF THIS
CONVERSATION IN PUTTING TOGETHER
A PLAN PUTTING THE OTHER SORT OF
WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE HOW WE
ULTIMATELY GET THERE SINCE WE
SEEM TO AGREE THAT WE NEED TO BE
REALLY FOCUSING ON FACILITIES.
BOTH ENSURING THAT THE
FACILITIES ARE CONDUCIVE TO THE
CATS REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS THAT
THAT WE KNOW WORK IN THAT THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE.
BUT ADDRESSING SOME OF THE OLDER
ONES IN AND
AND THEN I ALSO JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON THAT DJJ P.
SINCE YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
THAT IS VERY INTERESTING TO AND
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED A BE
THIRTEEN KNOW IT LAST YEAR
RECOGNIZING THE.
THE AGE AND ALL THE SCIENCE
REALLY POINTS THAT AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE AND I THINK THIS IS IN LINE
WITH IT.
BUT I THINK THERE'S SOME CONCERN
ABOUT.
HOLDING JUVENILE OFFENDERS
LONGER ABOUT NOT. GETTING THEM
BACK TO THEIR. LOCAL.
FACILITIES BECAUSE KIDS DO
BETTER WHEN THEY'RE CLOSER TO
HOME WHEN THEY'RE CLOSER TO
FAMILY. IN SO IF WE THINK WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL WITH
THIS AND IT I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THIS PROMISE OF KEEPING.
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS AWAY FROM THE
ADULT PRISONS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
LENGTHENING THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE INDEED JJ WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
STILL. ENSURING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE GOING BACK TO THE
JUVENILE. FACILITIES IN THEIR
COUNTIES AND WE NEED TO BOLSTER
THOSE PROGRAM SO THAT THEY ARE
STRONGER. THERE SO WE WERE NOT
PULLING KIDS UP TO STOCK TO
LEAVE THEM CLOSER THEIR
COMMUNITIES CLOSER THEIR
FAMILIES THEY TEND TO DO BETTER.
AND SO I I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
WITH THE DIRECTION WE'RE GOING
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT.
THAT. THAT WHOLE PROCESS.
SO HOLISTICALLY AND WHERE KIDS
NEED TO BE PLACED AS WE TRY TO
PROTECT THEM FROM GOING. INTO
ADULT POPULATIONS UNNECESSARILY
YOU IF YOU HAVE FAIR ENOUGH I
THINK THAT THE UNITED TYPE WE
HAD TEN THOUSAND YOU. FULL
OFFENDERS HAVE WITHIN DJJ TODAY
WE HAVE AROUND SIX HUNDRED
LITTLE OVER SIX HUNDRED.
WE ARE GETTING AND ONLY THE
MOST CHALLENGING CASES THE
COUNTIES ARE KEEPING MORE THE
JUVENILES.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH WITH
THIS OF PROPOSAL WOULD DO IS IF
AN OFFENDER.
THAT'S UNDER UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE.
IS DOING WELL IN BJJ.
IT'S REALLY JUST KEEPING THEM
IN THAT ENVIRONMENT CONTINUE
WITH THAT'S THAT WHEN HE
COMPLETES HIS SENTENCE HE CAN GO
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY BUT I
AGREE WITH YOU WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. I I DON'T
WANT YOU TO THINK THIS IS TAKING
OFFENDERS THAT ARE AN ADULT
PRISON. POPPING THEM AND DJJ
THAT IS NOT OUR INTENT IT NO NO
I UNDERSTAND YOUR TEN AND. THEN
I AGREE WITH THAT INTENT OF OF
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE SERVING
THEIR TIME.
WHERE THEY'RE BEING SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE AS SOON AS THEY GO TO
THE DOUGH? PRISON.
WHEN IT'S NOT REALLY WARRANTED
THAT HAS THAT CAN REALLY HURT
THEIR REHABILITATION AND HURT
WHO THEY ARE.
ON THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS IN
ASSURING THAT.
THAT WE'RE NOT CREATING
ENVIRONMENT WHERE KIDS MIGHT BE
INDEED JJ LONGER THAT WAR THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE GONNA BE BEING
HELD THE DJJ WHEN THEY REALLY
SHOULD BE WE SHOULD BE FINDING
WAYS TO GET THEM BACK TO THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITY. I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE SENSITIVITY IS NOT TO
THE AGE WHERE.
SPECIFICALLY THAT THEN THAT'S I
AGREE WITH YOU ON A PERSON
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO WORK ON.
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
I ACTUALLY HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS INTO IT AND MAYBE WE
CAN COOK BUT NO ONE IS HERE ALL.
ALL MORNING ON A SUB YOU CAN YOU
CAN WORK ON AND GET BACK.
.
BUT THEN I I'M ACTION REAL
SENSITIVE TO TO POSITION YOUR
URANUS AS A. VOICE IS A FORMER
BUREAUCRAT WHEN. YOU'RE AT THE
MERCY OF AYE NOW TALK ABOUT
ELECTED OFFICIALS ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO COME UP WITH THESE
IDEAS. LIKE PROP 47-57.
ONE AMOUNT AB ONE ON I.
WITHOUT REALLY CONSULTING WITH
THE PEOPLE LEFT IMPLEMENTED A
LOT OF TIMES YOU'RE CAUGHT.
WHICH YEAR WOULD NOT ENOUGH
RESOURCES NOW ENOUGH MONEY.
AND QUITE FRANKLY SOMETIMES IT'S
JUST A STUPID IDEA BUT WE YOU
HAVE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND SO I I.
I FEEL WHAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I'VE BEEN IN
THAT SAME SITUATION ON.
I WORK FOR THE CITY OF LA. AND
SO UP I I WANT TO WORK WITH YOU
THROUGH SOME OF THE STATE'S
CONCERNS AND IF YOU CAN SEE.
POPULATION IS IS NUMBER ONE ON
EVERYONE'S.
LIST RIGHT NOW.
AND I IMAGINE DJJ SALT BUT TO
START WITH THAT.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO NEED.
TO FIGURE THAT OUT AND EVEN
THOUGH IT MAY NOT TOTALLY BE
UNDER YOUR PURVIEW.
WHAT WE ARE I MEAN I AM
CONCERNED THAT I'VE BEEN TOLD IT
COSTS A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR HALF A KID?
THAT'S A GOOD YET J..
SO FOR A WHOLE KID IS LIKE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND WHICH IS LIKE
YOU KNOW I CAN GET THEM AT THE
S. C..
ON FOUR YEARS FELLOWSHIP AND.
ON ONE YEAR'S WORTH THE MONEY
THAT WE SPEND ON THEM. AND SO WE
WE NEED TO TALK THROUGH WHAT ARE
THEY WHAT SERVICES ARE REALLY
GETTING SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO COME TO YOU.
I MEAN LOOK AT THAT AMOUNT. ON.
SHIP CONDO AND.
PRIVATE TUTOR AND A WHOLE LOT OF
OTHER THINGS BUT. I.
I AM SENSITIVE TO. AS THE AGE
OUT WHAT HAPPENS
WITH YOU SO I GO ON A MISSION I
JUST RESPOND TO IT. REALLY QUICK
COMMUNITY GETS ECONOMY OF SCALE
WE HAVE SOME SIX HUNDRED WELL
ARMED YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS IN
THREE FACILITIES. I'M WOULD
PROVIDE THE MOST INTENSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND PROGRAMMING FOR THAT
POPULATION THAT YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY A NATIONAL.
MODEL IT IS IN CREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT AND I CERTAINLY SEE WHY
SOMEONE WOULD QUESTION AND I'VE
HEARD HEARD THE COMMENT YOU GET
SENDS STANFORD MAMA CONDOS
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTANDABLE.
PERCENT LIZZIE V. ALCAZAR.
THE MOST CHALLENGING MENTAL
HEALTH VIOLENT SEX OFFENDERS
THERE REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF EFFORT I BELIEVE TO TRY TO
GET THEM.
INTO A. PLACE WHERE THEY CAN BE
IN SOCIETY AND IT COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY TO DO SO. AND SO I I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION AND
AT IN HOW WE ADDRESS IT BUT I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT YOU
CAN WALK INTO OUR DJJ FACILITIES
TODAY. AND YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE A
STARK STARK DIFFERENCE THEN YOU
WOULD HAVE SAW. TEN YEARS AGO IN
WHICH YOU SEEN AS THE MOST
TROUBLED YOUTH IN OUR STATE.
GETTING SERVICES AND TRYING TO
GET THEM TO A POINT WHERE THEY
CAN GO BACK OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
AND BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND SO WE. DEATHLY ONE HAVE THAT
BECAUSE I I WILL TELL YOU.
BUT PEOPLE LIKE US DEVON WALKER
FROM.
CCPOA HAVE DONE A MASTERFUL JOB
AT TRYING TO EXPLAIN TO ME TO
POPULATION THAT EVEN THOUGH WE
MAY ABSENT. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE TO LOCAL LEVEL ONE NINE
47-57.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR MORE MONEY
AND MORE POSITIONS
AND AND AND SO HE'S HE'S HE'S
BEEN GOOD AT.
EXPLAINING THINGS TO ME PROBABLY
HAD TO DOUBLE DOWN FOR ME BUT I
I GET SOME OF THAT.
BUT.
I STILL NEEDS MORE EXPLANATION
TO GET ME COMFORTABLE AT AT ANY
LEVEL.
BOTH GIVING INCREASE IN IN
POSITIONS
OR OR OR.
BURKE THE BUDGET.
IN FACT I I WOULD RECOMMEND TO
DISHES I HAVE BOTH CHAIRS A
BUDGET OF FIVE AND IN A CHAIR
OF.
.
OUR BUDGET THT AND I'M GLAD
YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE I WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU HEAR FROM ME THAT WEEK
WE DON'T APPROVE ANY POSITIONS
AND WE DON'T APPROVE ANY
INCREASES IN BUDGET UNTIL WE.
HAVE THAT QUESTION ANSWER TO THE
SATISFACTION OF NOT ONLY JUST
COMMITTEE PITIFUL BUDGET
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE THAT THE MONIES
THAT WE GIVE YOU. ARE I SPENT
TWO TWO IN THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY
AND UP THAT NIGHT. FLAP THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN ASKING THIS
QUESTION FOUR SOMETIMES AFFECTED
WE KEEP COMING BACK AND ASKING
OVER AND OVER. I DON'T KNOW IF
WE NEED SOME KIND OF BICAMERAL
AUDIT WITH ALL LOOKED TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN EXPLAINED
IT TO US. BUT AT SOME POINT AND
WE PROBABLY NEED TO HAVE IT DONE
NOW OF WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO SEE
BY NOW TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THROUGH TO. TAXPAYERS.
Y. THIS SYSTEMS CONTINUALLY IS
IS EXPENDING TOO MUCH BUT A LOT
OF MONEY RIGHT NOW.
ARGOSY TOO MUCH BECAUSE AGAIN
I'M GIVE YOU THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT. THAT YOU MAY ACTUALLY
NEED THIS.
GREATLY INCREASES SINCE I'M NOT
GONNA MAKE THAT ASSUMPTION BUT
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND. IT'S
NOT.
IT'S NOT MAKING ANY SENSE TO US
AND IN THE SAME WITH. PEOPLE
COMING IN. BRING ELEMENT FROM
OUT OF STATE I THINK YOU'LL GET.
FULL AGREEMENT FROM DISK
COMMITTEE IN MOTION PEOPLE AND
ON BUDGET THAT WE WE NEED TO
PULL PEOPLE OUT OF LOS OUT OF
STATE PRISONS AND BRING IT BACK
HOME CLOSER TO TO FAMILIES. OF.
AS A FORMER DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE
ABSOLUTELY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BECAUSE THE MORE MONEY FOR HIM
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LESS MONEY
AFTER SPIN ON THE BACK AND.
ON TO BUILD NEW FACILITIES AND
SO MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE TO
DISCUSSION ALLEY ABOUT.
I'LL I DON'T KNOW SHE SAY CLOSE
PRISONS.
BUT I TALK ABOUT.
RECONFIGURING THEM.
DEBT DAY AIR BECOME
REHABILITATION CENTER.
PLACES WHERE WE SEND PEOPLE
THAT CAN IMPROVE THEIR LIVES
BETTER AND THAT.
FACILITY LIKE ELLIPTICAL HAPPY
PLACE BECOMES A PLACE WHERE.
WE'RE SENDING OUR FIGHT I WILL
SAY THAT OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST
WHO ARE INCARCERATED THAT WANT
TO TURN YOUR LIFE AROUND. AND WE
PUT PROVIDE A SPACE WHERE THEY
CAN'T.
SO.
S. DAEDALUS WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
A PRISON.
WILL DEFINITELY DO THAT.
BUT WHEN I OPEN UP THE LIGHT AT
THE OTHER END WHERE I WOULD PUT
A GROUP OF PROFESSIONALS.
SOCIAL WORKERS SO.
A PSYCHIATRIST TO GET PEOPLE
WHILE IT CRIMINALITY AND ON BACK
INTO THE STE BACK IN SOCIETY A
LOT QUICKER WITH A SKILL SET.
THAT ISLAM DOUBLE KEEPING GOING
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. BUT
IT FORTUNATE FOR YOU OF I'M I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
BIG PLAN WHICH WE JUST KIND OF
FORCED ON YOU RIGHT NOW AND UP I
WOULD LOVE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THAT FUTURE. BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT THIS COMMITTEE NEEDS WERE
IT NOT ONLY WHERE YOU CAN DO. I
KNOW YOU GET MIRED INTO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING RIGHT NOW. BUT WE
NEED I KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO FIVE
TO TEN YEARS FROM NOW WHAT YEAR
YOU YOU'RE AT THE. BEGINNING OF
SAID IN A WHOLE NEW WAY THAT WE
DO CORRECTIONS
AND WHAT YOU DO NOW CASSETTE
PRECEDENTS FOR THE NEXT FIVE OR
TEN YEARS AND SO THAT'S KIND OF
THE FRUSTRATION WERE GETTING
HERE. I KNOW IT'S IT'S TOUGH
WHEN YOU'RE FIGHTING BATTLES
EVERYDAY.
BUT WE NEED SOME VISIONARY STUFF
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
ABOUT WHERE YOU SEE US IN THE
NEXT FIVE OR TEN YEARS.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY FAIR
QUESTION AND YOU KNOW WHILE. WE
TRY TO MAKE THIS HISTORIC
CHANGES THAT ARE IS PROP FIFTY
SEVEN I DON'T WANT TO KNOW IF IT
IS A HISTORIC CHANGE I MEAN
EVERYBODY IN THE SYSTEM.
.
BOAT FLOATED IF I CAN SAY IT
LIKE THAT.
OTHER THAN CONDEMNED IN AL AQSA
A VAST VAST MAJORITY OF INMATES
NOW HAVE INCENTIVE TO GO
PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS AND EARN
THEIR WAY OUT IT IS REALLY
HISTORIC CHANGE IT'S BEING DONE
NOWHERE ELSE IN THE NATION. AND
YOU'RE RIGHT WE'VE BEEN UNDER
FIRE COMPLETELY FREELY FROM BOTH
SIDES BE A COURT ACTIONS ON ONE
SIDE OR. YOU KNOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE OTHERS AND I
THINK IT'S FAIR FOR YOU TO SAY
WHAT IS GOING TO BE THE VISION
INTO THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHY SOME OF OUR
REQUESTING MAY IMPLEMENT RIFTS
IN IN THOSE THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT.
FOR THAT PART OF IT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU AND
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE FIVE
YEARS TEN YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
BUT IS THIS AT THE SAME TIME
THAT WE TRY TO LOOK AT THAT
VISION AND MAYBE THIS IS.
YET MAYBE MY OWN FAILURES.
EVERY DAY IN OUR SYSTEM AS
POSITIVE AS I'M TELLING YOU.
MURDERS.
RIOTS SUICIDES O. DIS GANG
VIOLENCE.
THERE'S NO SET OF INTRACTABLE
PROBLEMS THAT WE COULD PUT
COUNTLESS DOLLARS WORDS I TRY TO
MAKE IT A BETTER SYSTEM AYE AYE
HAPPIER SYSTEM.
WE HAVE SPACE ISSUES WE'RE
LOOKING FOR TECHNOLOGY TO HELP
US DO THAT THERE'S ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS THAT. THEY NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN OUR BUDGET REQUESTS
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THAT BUT. I
JUST WANT YOU KNOW AND YOU BEEN.
VERY ENGAGED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
IN CORRECTIONAL ISSUES AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION SO
THAT WE CAN TRY TO DO IT SO
DON'T THINK YOU'RE HEAPING.
ANYMORE ON ME.
OF THIS DEPARTMENT IN THIS
PRISON SYSTEM NEEDS IT TODAY.
TRAIN UP A LEAVE YOU WITH.
WHAT WHAT I WOULD LIKE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO EMBRACE OTHER
CITY?
ALL I WANT YOU TO BE TOUGH ON
CRIME. BUT ALSO WHAT YOU BE
STRONG A REHABILITATION.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT MODEL.
IT'S WHAT YOU TAKE COME FROM
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK YOU PROBABLY GLEAN FROM
THE COMMENTS OF OF LOUNGE.
I'M SORRY IT'S KNOW SLIPKNOT
I'M.
I I DIDN'T SEE HIM SO GOOD WAS
SITTING.
MR SECRETARY THANK YOU SO JUST
GOING BACK TO ON.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
SANTA CRUZ'S POINT ON YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF.
PERMANENT ONGOING BUDGET
REQUESTS ARE CORRECTING HERE IS
A PERMANENT ONGOING POSITIONS
THESE ARE NOT NONE OF THEM ARE
TEMPORARY GO FOR THE DJJ YES BUT
I DON'T KNOW BUT JUST BUT JUST
FOR YOUR BUT YOUR THROUGH. CCR
BUDGETS.
UNLIKE VARIOUS ITEMS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED IN TERMS OF STAFFING
THINGS LIKE AND THESE ARE
PERMANENT ONGOING BETTER IF THEY
INVOLVED A. YOU KNOW POSITION
JUST SO THEY WOULD BE ONGOING
THANK YOU.
IN AND IS A POPULATION THAT
YOU'RE SERVING DECLINE CAN YOU
PREDICT THE DECLINE.
IT'S STARTING DECLINE AND DO YOU
FORESEE IT TO CONTINUE TO
KREIDER DO YOU FORESEE.
AND IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS TO
PROVE DO YOU BELIEVE IN WHAT THE
CLIENT.
AT THIS POINT IN YOUR THE IT FOR
WHAT I THINK YOU'RE PROP FIFTY
SEVEN IS ALLOWED TO WORK I THINK
IF THERE'S NO INITIATIVES THAT
AND DO. THOSE POPULATION.
CHANGES THAT YES I THINK THAT
THE POPULATION WILL DECLINE.
PROP FIFTY SEVEN I THINK
PROJECTED ABOUT.
ELEVEN THOUSAND OR SO.
IN THAT THREE YEARS OUT TOLD
OVER THAT SAME TIME FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS DO YOU FORESEE YOUR
BUDGET GOING UP OR DOWN.
SEE GOING UP.
AND WHY IS THAT I THINK THAT
THAT WE HAVE A BILLION OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND WE HAVE NOT
INVESTED FOR YEARS AND YEARS. TO
ADDRESS ROUGH SAN AIR HANDLING
UNITS HAVE PRISONS IN THE DESERT
THAT GET A HUNDRED TWENTY
DEGREES AND. I NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS IS STRONG. AS A SAID IN OUR
BUDGET REQUESTS AND THIS IS
JUST.
TO ADDRESS SOME A MEDIA ISSUES.
THAT THAT I THINK THAT.
BROUGH THAT A STATE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO INVEST IN THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION
ASSETS FOR MANY YEARS TO COME IT
WOULD BE OUR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. I WITH THE SPIKE
APPEARED.
WE'RE YOU. KNOW WHAT WAS YOUR
RETURN ON INVESTMENT YOU'RE
ASKING PUBLIC SAFETY LAWSUITS I.
SENT IN THE ATTACHMENTS THAT I
I SENT THEM YOU CAN JUST READ
THE PRISON LAW OFFICES LETTER IT
IS CLEAR WHILE THEY'VE SUIT IS
SO. YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN OVER.
WE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH IS BEEN UNDER
OVERSIGHT OF THE FEDERAL COURT
FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS. ON THIS
IS THE NEXT STRATEGY THIS IS THE
NEXT LAWSUIT. THAT WE HAVE GOT
TO ADDRESS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
JOBS I JUST AFFECT THE FINANCIAL
ESTIMATE AS TO WHAT THE RETURN
INVESTMENTS COULD BE FROZE.
HOME AT IT BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU MEAN BY RETURN WELL YOU'RE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY.
AND WHAT IS THE FINANCIAL
BENEFIT FOR THE STATE TO GIVE
YOU THE ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATIONS OVER THE.
FROM.
I'M CHARGED WITH HOUSING
OFFENDERS THAT ARE COMMITTED BY
THE COURTS AND SO.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT ALWAYS
DISCUSSION ABOUT MASS
INCARCERATION SPIRALING OUT A
STATE I MEAN SPIRALING BUDGETS.
.
THOUGH OVER INCARCERATION OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR YOU KNOW ALL OF
THOSE THOSE ISSUES STEPS IT
BEFORE SO I HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE ABOUT
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND INMATES
TODAY.
AND GROWS ABOUT A THOUSAND.
YEAR.
SO IN WHAT WE DO THESE
POPULATION REDUCTION MEASURES TO
REDUCE LIKE PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
YOU HOPE THAT YOU WILL SEE A
DECLINE IN THE POPULATION BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S.
IN STONE THAT THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN THEN I SO I DON'T KNOW IF
I CAN GET YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
RETURN ON INVESTMENT BUT I THINK
THAT THE PRISON PRISON SYSTEMS
INTERCALL TO KEEPING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I THINK THE LEADING LEADING THE
COURTS JUST LET OUT INMATES.
IT'S TERRIBLE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WE WILL RUE THE DAY THAT
THAT HAPPENS
AND SO WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
TO KEEP OUR PRISON SYSTEM UP
INCARCERATED PEOPLE THAT COME TO
US FROM THE COURTS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY. DISAGREES WITH.
YOUR STATEMENT BUT AGAIN THIS
IS A. BUDGET COMMITTEE MY MY
FABULOUS COLLEGE IN LOS ANGELES
CHAIRS A POLICY COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T DEAL WITH SUCH COMPLEX
ISSUES HERE WHICH IS TO WHAT
BUDGETARY ISSUES.
SO HOME FINANCIALLY I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR ARMY.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE ONLY
DEPARTMENTS WERE THE POPULATION
THAT YOU'RE SERVING IS GOING
DOWN AND YOU ARE ASKING FOR MORE
MONEY.
ENTERED FROM A STATE
PERSPECTIVE
I I CAN'T THINK OF ANOTHER.
AGENCIES ETCETERA SIMILAR
POSITIONS I THINK FROM OUR.
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT I THINK YOU
NEED TO.
SIT DOWN WITH MISTER JONES
SAWYER TALKED WEBER A BETWEEN
NOW AND MAY TO REALLY.
PROVIDE SOME. LONGER TERM
JUSTIFICATION YOU'RE ASKING FOR.
PERMANENT LONGER TERM
AUGMENTATION. WITHOUT A PLAN ARE
YOUR POPULATIONS GOING DOWN.
YOU HAVEN'T DEMONSTRATED
FINANCIALLY WHAT THE BENEFIT IS
AND SO IT'S VERY VERY.
UNCHALLENGING. THE BUDGET'S
GOING UP ABOUT.
.
PLEASE HAVE JUST IN GENERAL
NUMBERS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO ELEVEN FIVE
LAST YEAR TWELVE PERCENT WITH A
PERCENT OF YOUR BUDGET.
TO.
I THINK ABOUT TWO AND AND I'LL
AND I'LL GIVE ME JUST IN THE
POPULATIONS DOWN EX PERCENT
WHERE WHERE'S MY POINT SIR. FOUR
HUNDRED AND THAT IS AN EMPLOYEE
CALL. FOUR HUNDRED IS RAISES
FOR MY STAFF THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED.
LET THE BUDGET REQUEST THAT I
HAVE BEFORE YOU ARE TO THE EDGE
YOU KNOW IT WAS KIND OF MY POINT
MAYBE IN OUR POLICE SAID TO TRY
TO SUPPORT CHANGING THE SYSTEM.
WHICH WHICH WE WANT TO DO BUT WE
DID PAID IT DOWN AND AGAIN I
HEAR YOU'RE VERY LUCKY OF THREE.
FABULOUS MEMBERS WHO ARE.
FAR IN FAR MORE INTELLIGENT THAN
ME SO I NEED TO HAVE THINGS A
LITTLE MORE SIMPLE.
HOME.
I DON'T SEE THE JUSTIFICATION
AND I DON'T SEE HOME AGAIN THE.
THIRD THINK SO I'M NOT SAYING
THAT WE.
CAN'T GET THAT THINKING BETWEEN
NOW IN MAY WHEN WE SHUT DOWN
THIS PROCESS.
BUT THAT'S WHAT WERE I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AND YOU KNOW YOU KNOW WE WE WANT
TO BE. THOUGHT WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE
OF THE VISION.
BUT AGAIN I'M THAT THE WAY I
LOOK AT THE. IT'S IT'S SORT OF
LIKE GOT INCENTIVES WE GET A WE
YOUR DOOR SORT OFASKING. FOR
INCENTIVES
TO. IMPROVE TO RE ENVISION THE
SYSTEM I KNOW THESE ARE CHICKENS
COMING TO ROOST OVER THIRTY
FORTY YEARS OF POLICIES THAT.
WERE WHERE HAPPENED A HINDSIGHT
BEING TWENTY TWENTY BE LOOKING
AT AND I THINK EVERYONE IS
PATIENT AND OPEN TO VERY MUCH
SUPPORTING THAT CHANGE IN
DIRECTION.
THAT SOME POINT.
SHIPS TURNED AND YOU'RE MOVING
IN THE DIRECTION YOU NEED TO GO.
AND I THINK THE BUDGET EASTER
REFLECT.
SO WE JUST WANT TO KNOW WHEN
THAT.
DAY YES THAT'S FAIR ENOUGH FROM
THE ONLY THING I WOULD.
I'D LIKE TO SEE CHEN I'D LIKE TO
HAVE THE DIALOGUE AND IN.
DO A BETTER JOB OF TRYING TO
IMPRESS ON YOU. ALONE KNOW SOME
OF THE IMPACTS THAT IMPACT OUR
BUDGET AND IT IS EMPLOYEE COPIED
IS. INCREASED HEALTH CARE COSTS
INCREASE MENTAL HEALTH COSTS
THAT WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OF INACTION I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT THE
AGENCY I HAD JUST SEEN THE STATE
HAS WILL FINISH.
EVER SINCE I'VE BECOME ONE OF
THE ONLY AGENCIES THAT'S.
TAKING CARE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND GALLONS
THAT YOU KNOW OUR DOT ORG
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
TO DO IT AND THEN IT'S.
YOU KNOW IT IS HE'D SPEW SO
SIMPLE ABOUT IT BUT IT.
THAT THAT COSTS THAT WE THAT
INCUR ARE THE PRICE PREEMIE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED DJJ
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF THE MOST
VIOLENT.
NO MURDERS INDETERMINATE
SENTENCE SEX OFFENDERS.
MENTAL HEALTH FORTY THOUSAND OF
MY POPULATION IS MENTALLY ILL
THAT REQUIRES US
COURT ORDERED STAFF BEING. ALL
MY MEDICAL SO A HEALTH CARE
OPERATIONS HAS BEEN UNDER
RECEIVERSHIP FOR OVER TWELVE
YEARS THEY ORDER MORE STAFF AND
SO THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURES ON
A ON. THE BUDGET BUT I DO AGREE
WITH YOU THAT WE OWE YOU AN
EXPLANATION WELL AND THERE'S AND
THERE'S PRESSURE ON US TO THIS
PRESSURE US IN TERMS OF HEALTH
CARE CAL WORKS CAL FRESH HIGHER
EDUCATION K. TWELVE.
SO HOME I UNDERSTAND YOUR
SITUATION IS SPECIAL THAT EVERY
AGENCY IN THIS STATE IS SPECIAL
ALSO GET AHOLD THAT.
.
ALFA GHETTO THAT'S HERE THAT
WHAT YOU THINK YOU'RE THE ONLY
STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M NOT BUT I GET PAID TO.
DEFEND MY DEPARTMENT IN THE
PEOPLE THAT I'M IN CHARGE WITH
INCARCERATING. AND SO THAT'S THE
ONLY DISTINCTION LIKE NOTHING
AGAINST ALL OF THOSE OTHER VERY
IMPORTANT PRIORITY ONE THIS
COMMITTEE GETS
GETS PAID TERM. MANAGE THE
STATE'S RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE GETTING THE RIGHT RETURN
ON INVESTMENT
SO WHEN YOU CAN PROPERLY IT'S
THAT QUESTION THAT WE CAN
PROPERLY MAKE THAT DECISION.
SO ARM FOR FOR US.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT YOUR MISSION.
ABSOLUTELY AND WE WANT TO
SUPPORT TO DIRECTOR GOMANTAK
GOES BACK TO MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A PLAN
THAT YOU PUT TOGETHER YOUR TEAM
PUT TOGETHER.
THAT IS TAUGHT FULL BLACK HARM
THAT PROVIDES US DIRECTION LONG
TERM VISION BUT IN IN ABSENCE OF
THE PLAN THEN IT'S.
BECOMES AND WE HAVE TO DEVELOP.
WHICH WE WOULD RATHER NOT DO
YOUR. YOUR THEM SECRETARY YOUR
THE DEPARTMENT HEAD YOU WE WHAT
WE WANT YOUR PLAN WOULD WANT OUR
PLAN.
.
YOU AND YOUR DEATH WE DON'T ON
OUR PLANET.
SO.
WELL WELL.
WE WANT IS AGAIN YOUR GUIDANCE
YOUR INTELLIGENCE YOUR DAY TO
DAY ANALYSIS BUT.
ARE YOU ASKING FOR PERMANENT.
ONGOING FUNDS.
AND AT SOME POINT YOU NEED TO
TELL US.
WHEN THAT'S GONNA HEAD.
OTHERWISE HE SHALL BE TEMPORARY
POSITIONS.
SO AGAIN ON. YOUR WE WE WE DEAL
WITH PRETTY SIMPLE THINGS IN
THIS COMMITTEE AND THERE THEY
HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH DOLLARS
AND CENTS YOU. YOU GIVE ME A LOT
OF GREAT RHETORIC A LOT OF THIS
A LOT OF THAT.
SHOW ME THE NUMBERS.
AND THEN WE CAN TALK.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER.
SECRETARY CURRENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AYE I DON'T IF I CAN ADD
ANYTHING WHAT AT THAT AFTER THIS
OF THE YOU KNOW BUDGET YEAR
SPOKEN BUT. CLEARLY I THINK WHAT
WHAT AT AND I THINK YOU GET THE
MESSAGE THAT.
EVEN IN THE RIP. IN THE THOUGHT
THAT IF WE DO INCREASES
WEATHERED AND STAFF OR FUNDING
OR BUDGET. THE SUCTION IS THAT
THERE IS A LARGER PLAN DOWN THE
ROLE THAT IT COOPER THAT THESE
IF WE MAKE THE.
INCREASE IN SAY RESOURCES THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT THAT WE WILL
NOT HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THE POPULATION THAT
MEASLES RESOURCES WILL DECLINE.
I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT FOR THOSE WHO
ARE MOST AFFECTED BY IT AND
WHAT'S THE STAFF OF THESE
FACILITIES TO ACTUALLY COME UP.
WITH A PLAN BECAUSE BUT NO ONE
WRITES A PLAN THAT CREATES THEIR
EXTINCTION I MEAN SELDOM DO THEY
DO THAT ALSO AS A RESULT I THINK
THAT'S WHY WE LOOK AT THE LA WAS
KIND OF AN INDEPENDENT BODY.
THAT'S LOOKING AT IT THAT WE'VE
MADE A COMMENT LAST YEAR IN THE.
IN THE BUDGET HEARINGS THAT.
THAT CLEARLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPAIRS THAT NEED TO BE MADE AND
ONE OF OUR MY CONCERNS IT'S BEEN
ALWAYS THAT. WE NEED TO KNOW.
UP IF IT MAKING THE REPAIRS AT
THE FACILITY SLOW LAST LONGER.
IN TERMS OF THE NEEDS OF THE
POPULATION SO WHY BUILD A BRAND
NEW ROOF ON A BUILDING THAT NEXT
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO SHUT DOWN.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONCERNS AND A WHAT I LOOKED AT
THE LA GOALS ARE RECOMMENDATION
WITH REGARDS TO NORCO
PARTICULARLY.
YOU KNOW THEY WERE LOOKING AT
THE FACT THAT THAT THAT THE
REPAIR ON THAT FACILITY IS IT'S
ENORMOUS. AND IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
.
EVENTUALLY SHUTTING DOWN A
PRISON WHY WOULD YOU MAKE THOSE
THAT LEVEL OF REPAIR. ON A ON A
FACILITY IF IF YOU MAY END UP
CLOSING THE FACILITY AND THAT
ONE OBVIOUSLY HAS THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF REPAIR ISSUES AND
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS SO. I
THINK LAST YEAR WE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT TO SAY IF WE WERE TO
CLOSE A PRISON WHICH ONE WOULD
BE CLOSE AND WHAT WILL BE THE
CONDITION OF THE OF THE. PRISON
THAT WE CLOSED AND I WORDS WE
DON'T WANT TO REPAIR RULES ON TO
A PLACE THAT'S GOING TO BE
CLOSED I MEAN THAT KIND OF STUFF
BECAUSE THE REST OF THE
EXPENSIVE. OR TO GET INVOLVED IN
A WHOLE LOT OF CHANGES IN
TECHNOLOGY IN THIS IN THAT ONLY
TO DISCOVER. THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE PRISONS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE I THINK LOOKING AT A PLAN.
THAT IF WE MOVE IN A CERTAIN
DIRECTION WHAT WHAT THAT PLAN
LOOKED LIKE.
AND DO WHAT RESOURCES MIGHT BE
SAVED IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT.
EVER SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
ONLY THE BUDGET FOR.
.
THIS DEPARTMENT HAS INCREASED
SOMETIMES A ENORMOUSLY MUCH MORE
THAN SOME OF THE OTHERS AND I
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE OF POPULATION
KEPT GROWING. AND WILL HEAL A
BIT MORE ABOUT POPULATION IN A
MINUTE THAT THE GUARDS TO WHY WE
DID ALSO SEEMS TO BE GOING UP
AND DOWN. IN CERTAIN AREAS BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE. THAT
VISION THAT IF WE ARE BOTH WITH
GIVING SOMEONE ASKED IF YOU GET
A MAKING PERMANENT POSITIONS ARE
WE GONNA NEED THOSE PERMANENT
POSITIONS. IN THE FUTURE AMID IF
WE IF WE REDUCING POPULATION AND
THE OTHER ISSUES DO YOU HAVE
ENOUGH FOLKS RETIRING TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT IF THERE IS A
REDUCTION.
I MEAN THOSE KINDS OF ARGUMENTS
WOULD BE HELPFUL AYE IF WE LOOK
AT THE POSITIONS BECAUSE IF
THERE AYE IF PEOPLE THERE ARE A
CERTAIN AGE IN MAY BE. LOOKING
AT RETIREMENT AND X. THREE FOUR
FIVE YEARS AND YOU BRING YOU
KNOW PERMIT PEOPLE THEN THAT'S
MAKES SENSE BUT IF YOU BRING UP
PERMITS. INDIVIDUALS AND THERE'S
NO.
.
FOLKS RETIRING WITHIN GOD HAVE
TO GET INVOLVED IN LAOS AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU DO LAYOFFS
EVERYBODY GOES CRAZY OKAY. AND
UP AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONCERNS OF THAT THAT WE HAVE.
SO I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS.
AND.
AND YOUR ENTHUSIASM FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING OBVIOUSLY
PROP FIFTY SEVEN HAS ALL
LOOKING.
AT THINGS IT TO HOPEFULLY WILL
BE A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PICTURE
BUT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON THE AGENDA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND. THINK WHAT WE
HAVE DONE AND FOR ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS THE CDC OUR
POPULATION OVERVIEW. OF WILL
HAVE SOMEONE FROM.
CDC ARE.
HERE AS WELL AS APARTMENT
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OF WILL TAKE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH SIX
ALTOGETHER.
I. SINCE OUT AGAIN WITH THEM
BOTH WANT THE SIX I GIVE THE
MEMBERS HERE AN OPPORTUNITY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OF. THE
INDIVIDUALS ON ITEMS ONE THROUGH
SIX BECAUSE MOST OF THEM ARE
PROBABLY JUST REPORTING OUT OF
INFORMATION.
AND THEN AFTER THAT IF THERE
ARE ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
EITHER ITEM ONE THROUGH SIX WE
WILL. TAKE THOSE PUBLIC COMMENTS
AT THAT TIME SO WE. THERE ARE
PLEASE FILL WHICH ITEM YOU
TALKING ABOUT THEN WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE ITEM SEVENTY NINE IT
NEEDS EACH ONE OF THOSE BECAUSE
THEY ARE DIFFERENT WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUAL
COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE. AND
THEN FINALLY ITEMS TEN AND
ELEVEN WE TAKEN TOGETHER AND
THEY WILL BASICALLY HAVE
COMMENTS ONLY AFTER THE END OF
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SO I TRIED
WILL TRY TO GIVE US WHAT MAKES
SENSE OR NOT GOING BACK TO. BACK
AND FORTH IN THE AUDIENCE WITH
FOLKS OF FIGURING OUT WHO'S
GOING TO COME AT WHAT TIME.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME.
AS WE GET A DEAL ITEM NUMBER
ONE.
THANK YOU COULD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JASON LOPEZ
CDC ARE.
AS YOU MENTIONED ITEM NUMBER
ONE UP ON THE AGENDA IS OUR
POPULATION OVER YOU.
THE DEPARTMENT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR TWICE A YEAR.
OUR OFFICE OF RESEARCH WILL
PRODUCE OUR POPULATION ESTIMATES
FOR A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT CLASS
OF OFFENDERS WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
I'M JOINED TODAY BY CHRIS
CHAMBERS WHO IS OUR ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF OR OFFICE OF
RESEARCH IS GONNA WALK YOU
THROUGH QUICKLY AND OVERVIEW OF
THAT AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
PART SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR WEBER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
CHRIS CHAMBERS AND I CURRENTLY
SERVICE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH WITH.
SEE OUR.
THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH PREPARE
CDC OURS ADULT. INSTITUTION AND
PROP PROP ELATION FORECASTS AND
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
UPDATE THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON THESE
PROJECTIONS.
THE POPULATION PROJECTIONS ARE
PREPARED TWICE ANNUALLY ONCE IN
THE SPRING AND ONCE IN THE FALL
OF EACH YEAR.
THESE PROJECTIONS ARE DEVELOPED
USING HISTORICAL TREND DATA AND
TIME SERIES FORECASTING
TECHNIQUES.
OUR CURRENT VERSION IS THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FALL POPULATION
PROJECTION REPORT. WHICH WAS
JUST RELEASED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE ADULT BUT INSTITUTION
POPULATION WAS ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY OFFENDERS.
ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ARE PROJECTION FOR
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IS ONE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
OFFENDERS
THIS IS A ONE YEAR DE INCREASE
OF NEARLY THREE THOUSAND
OFFENDERS ARE APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT THREE PERCENT.
AS OF OUR LAST WEEK WE PUBLISHED
REPORT.
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE ADULT INSTITUTION
POPULATION STANDS AT ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND.
FOUR HUNDRED AND THREE.
ANNUALLY ADULT INSTITUTION
POPULATION GROWTH IS EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE DECLINING IN THE NEXT
TO BUDGET CYCLES.
CHIEFLY RESPONSIBLE AS
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN.
ENHANCE CREDIT EARNING.
THESE ENHANCEMENTS BEGAN
AFFECTING THE FENDER POPULATION
AT THE END OF JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
WHICH STARTS THE FAULT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN POPULATION PROJECTION
CYCLE.
SINCE OUR ACTUAL RELEASE DATE IS
STILL IN THE BEGINNING STAGES WE
RECOMMEND CAUTION BE EMPLOYED
WHEN INTERPRETING. THESE VERY
EARLY PROJECTIONS.
PLEASE KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUALLY REFINES OUR LOGIC
STAYING ABREAST WITH CURRENT
INSTITUTION ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE DOES THIS PUT US IN THIS
WERE DISCUSSED BUT THE STATE
INTO YOUR SAY JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY?
THE DOT INSTITUTION POPULATIONS
PROJECTED AT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE.
FOR JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY.
THIS PROJECTION WOULD RESULT IN
A TWO YEAR DECREASE OF TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
OFFENDERS.
MOVING TO PEROT PROJECTIONS
APPROPRIATION WAS FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE.
AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
OUR PROJECTION FOR JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN.
THIS IS A ONE YEAR INCREASE OF
SEVEN POINT EIGHT PERCENT.
FROM HERE THE PRO POPULATION IS
EXPECTED TO INCREASE FURTHER IN
THE NEXT TO BUDGET CYCLES.
AS FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE PAROLE POPULATION
STANDS FOR FORTY SIX THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY THREE.
A DOCTOR WEBER AND BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS HERE.
IF I COULD JUST PROVIDE  LITTLE
MORE CONTEXT FOR THE NUMBER SO
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'RE GONNA
SEE AS MISTER CHAMBERS IS GOING
THROUGH HIS NUMBERS AND YOU'RE
COMPARING THEM TO THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU SEE IN THE BUDGET. IS
OUR OFFICE OF RESEARCH OFTEN
DEALS WITH POINT IN TIME DATA
WHERE.
THE BUDGET IS BASED ON AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATION SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE A SLIGHT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE. TWO NUMBERS.
PART OF FINANCE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
NOTHING AT THIS TIME DILIO.
CAITLYN O'NEILL LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I IN GENERAL WE WITHHOLD
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ON THAT
POPULATION DRIVEN BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS AND TELL THEM A
REVISION. HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S
PLANNED TO ACCOMMODATE THE
ANTICIPATED POPULATION
REDUCTIONS RESULTING FROM
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN.
AND WE DON'T RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROJECTIONS OF THE IMPACT OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN ON THE
INMATE POPULATION.
HOWEVER WE THINK THAT THE INMATE
POPULATION DECLINE THAT THEY'RE
PROJECTING. PRESENTS THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES.
AND WE FIND. THAT CDC ARE COULD
CLOSE A STATE PRISON AND STILL
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT.
REDUCTION IN THESE ABOUT A
STATE CONTRACT BEDS BY CLOSING
THE FACILITY IN MISSISSIPPI.
HOWEVER TO DO THAT AND TO
MAINTAIN THE SAME LEVEL OF
OVERCROWDING IN OUR STATE OWNED
AND OPERATED PRISONS AS WOULD BE
MAINTAINED UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN. THE STATE WOULD HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THE ARIZONA CONTRACT.
ONE POSSIBLE PRISON TO CLOSE AS
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED ALREADY IS
THE CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
CENTER IN NORCO.
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY THAT
GOVERN THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED CLOSING IN THE PAST
DUE TO ITS DETERIORATING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AT THAT TIME.
AS MADE IT WOULD COST OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO FULLY
RENOVATE.
WE ESTIMATE THAT CLOSING THE
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION CENTER
AND THE MISSISSIPPI CONTRACT
FACILITY WOULD EVENTUALLY RESULT
IN ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN AND.
SAVINGS RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN.
I WOULD ALSO AVOID THE NEED TO
RENOVATE CRC.
HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ON OUR PROPOSAL COULD
TEMPORARILY RESULT IN LOWER
SAVINGS MATH RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN WHILE CRC IS
BEING CLOSED. BUT IN THE LONG
TERM WE EXPECT THE SAVINGS WOULD
GREATLY EXCEED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER DIRECTING
STYLE CDC ARE TO CLOSE YOUR SEE
AND THE MISSISSIPPI FACILITY.
INSTEAD OF CLOSING BOTH OUT OF
STATE CONTRACT FACILITIES IF THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES.
TO CLOSE YEAR SEE WE RECOMMEND
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE IT WITH THE PLAN ON THE
PRINT ON THE CLOSURE. IF IT
DECIDES NOT TO CLOSE YEAR SEE WE
RECOMMEND DIRECTING CDC ARE TO
PROVIDE IT WITH A PLAN TO MAKE
THE NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AT CRC.
AND MADAM CHAIR OF NOW IS AN
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D BE GLAD TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THAT ABOUT
CONCERNS THAT SECRETARY KERN AND
BROUGHT UP.
SO FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT AWARE
OF A COURT ORDER THAT REQUIRES
THE STATE TO ELIMINATE ITS USE
OF OUT OF STATE CONTRACT
FACILITIES.
HOWEVER THIS THE COURT HAS
ORDERED THE STATE TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE LEVELS OF HEALTH CARE
TO INMATES.
AND BECAUSE SEE ARE SEE WHAT'S
UP PLAN FOR CLOSURE IN THE PAST
AND NEVER RECEIVED A HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECT AS
MANY OTHER PRISONS HAVE.
ANY FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTEEN
COURT ORDER WHICH I BELIEVE THE
SECRETARY WAS REFERRING TO AND
THE COURT SAID THAT DEFENDANTS
SHALL EXPLORE WAYS TO ATTEMPT TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF INMATES
HOUSED IN OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES TO THE EXTENT
FEASIBLE. SINCE THAT TIME THE
STATE HAS REDUCED ITS EAT AT
RICH IT'S.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF INMATES IN
OUT OF STATE FACILITIES BY MORE
THAN HALF.
AND UNDER THE ALTERNATIVE FOR A
APPROACH THAT WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER THE STATE
WOULD BE CONTINUING TO MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE USE
OF OUT OF STATE CONTRACT BEDS.
IN LESS THE INMATE POPULATION
DECREASES UNEXPECTEDLY BEYOND
WHAT IS ANTICIPATED BY
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN AS A
RESULT OF TOP PROPOSITIONS FIFTY
SEVEN. THIS STATE WILL HAVE TO
UNDERTAKE COSTLY REPAIRS
RENOVATIONS AT CRC TO MAKE IT
FEASIBLE TO CONTINUE HOUSING
INMATES THERE IN THE LONG TERM.
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
PROPOSED A PLAN TO DO SO.
AND THEN SECOND ON THE ON THE
CONCERNS ABOUT INMATES BEING
FURTHER FARTHER AWAY FROM
FAMILIES IN WHILE IN ME ARIZONA
FACILITY. I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
TO KNOW THAT.
FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT A THIRD OF
THE INMATE POPULATION WAS
COMMITTED. FROM LA COUNTY AND
LOS ANGELES IS ABOUT A SEVEN
HOUR DRIVE FROM ELY ARIZONA
WHERE THAT WHERE THE CONTRACT
FACILITY IS LOCATED. AND NOT AND
THERE ARE THREE STATE PRISONS
THAT ARE GREATER THAN A THREE
HOUR DRIVE FROM.
LOS ANGELES SO IT'S IT'S
REASONABLE TO THINK THAT IF IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER MOVE OUT OF THE
OUT OF STATE FACILITY IS
ACTUALLY FARTHER FOR MANY
PEOPLE'S FAMILIES.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
OKAY.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS IN ONE.
YEAH EXCEPT I'VE HAD LITTLE
CHAMADA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET ACT IT'S JUST A
DELAYED CLOSURE AS THIS IS STILL
CONSISTENT WITH OUR PREVIOUS
PLAN. AND.
A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF SEARS
HE'S INFRASTRUCTURE IS STILL
BEING COMPLETED AYE AND WON'T BE
COMPLETED UNTIL THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WHICH WOULD
TELL US SOME OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THEIR.
AND AS SECRETARY CURLY NOTED I.
CONTINUING THE USE OF OUT OF
STATE DISS NEITHER DESIRABLE NOR
A DURABLE SOLUTION.
SO YOU SAYING THAT THE ACTUAL
ANALYSIS OF THE OF THE REPAIRS
AND NEEDS WILL NOT BE DONE UNTIL
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SEC WRECKED THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND SHOULD
UNDERSTAND.
OH OKAY I I THOUGHT THAT.
I MEAN THIS PRISONERS BEEN ON
THE.
DISCUSSION AND CHOPPING BLOCK
WE'VE ME FLY WAS CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO I'M TRYING TO. HAVE
SOMEONE WAS TO MADE SOME
ASSESSMENT THERE AND THERE HAS
BEEN SOME FORM OF AN ASSESSMENT
DONE AND I THINK A MACHINE
MISSED ISHIMOTO IS REFERRING TO.
.
WE SECURE FUNDING.
EITHER LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE TO DO AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE NEEDS THAT ARE TWELVE ALL
THIS PRISONS. SEE OUR SAMPLING
ONE OF THOSE SO THE MORE FORMAL
ASSESSMENT THAT SHE'S REFERRING
TO WILL BE READY YOU KNOW
CALDERON HERE. THANK YOU UPS
RIGHT BECAUSE I SOMEWHERE SAW
THAT THERE WAS SOME.
NUMBERS IN DISCUSSIONS OF SCOPE
OF WHAT MARCO INSIDE AT TIMES
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. OKAY. WE
WERE DOING A NEW ONE BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE UPDATE.
IN PART FIFTY SEVEN IS GOING TO
HELP THE STATE REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION BUT I UNDERSTAND IT
THE FELON IN MISSIONS ARE GOING
UP.
DO WE HAVE A REASON
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE FACTORS
DRIVING THESE INCREASES.
MADAM CHAIRMAN AT THIS POINT I
WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK IN AND
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT INFORMATION
CAN GET BACK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON THAT OKAY. LOOK FOR TO THAT
INFORMATION WITH US BECAUSE WE
WERE. WE WANT TO KNOW WE DON'T.
BUT IF THERE'S SOMETHING OUT
THERE THAT'S HAPPENING THAT'S
CAUSING PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
COMMIT MORE CRIMES OF MORE
FELONIES. OF RELATING WHAT ONE
TWO AND WAS STILL BRINGING IN
THE WHOLE TRUTH THE OTHER
DIRECTION. A WHICH WOULD
OBVIOUSLY PUT A SET UP MINUS
INTO BLOGGING IF I CAN ADD WE
NOTED INCREASE IN ADMISSIONS
STARTING IN THE LATTER HALF OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN. OF ALL
DETERMINEDLY SENTENCED
COMMITMENTS BUT A GREATER
INCREASED WAS OBSERVED AT SECOND
STRIKER COMBAT.
COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS FISCAL
YEAR ALTHOUGH THAT CONTINUE THE
LAST YEAR WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
THOSE NUMBERS SOMEWHAT FLATTENED
OUT.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH.
TIME THAT HAS PROGRESSED TO
ACTUALLY GIVE IT A FAIR TREND
ANALYSIS ON THAT WHICH IS WHY I
WANT TO GO BACK.
AND GET MORE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
BUT WE ARE CONTINUING TO ENGAGE
IN BROADER ANALYSIS OF OF IN
REVIEW OF CRIME GOAL. OF
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
TRENDS.
OKAY WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING THAT THANK YOU. OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS APPEAR.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
VARIATIONS ON STANDARD AYE
STAFFING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WITH ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
YOU.
YOU ALL ARE USED TO SEEING THIS.
JUSTMAN EVERY YEAR TO OUR
SENATE AYE STAFFING PACKAGE
YOU'LL RECALL THAT. BACK IN THE
BLUEPRINT WE ESTABLISHED THE
STANDARD AYE STAFFING
METHODOLOGY.
IN ORDER TO.
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT MORE
EFFICIENTLY RUN OUR PRISONS.
AND MORE EFFECTIVELY RUN OUR
PRISONS THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
INVOLVES AND I REQUEST FOR FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
AND THIRTY ONE POINT SIX
POSITIONS INCLUDING CEOS AND
SERGEANTS.
MAJORITY THE POSITIONS ARE TIED
TO STAFFING.
THE COMPLETED EXCEPT PROJECTS
AT A VARIETY OF INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE DETAILED IN YOUR
AGENDA.
AND.
I HAVE WITH ME JUST FOR BREAD
AND WHO IS THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OUR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS SHE'S GONNA
RIDE A JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION WILL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OUR STANDARD AYE STAFFING
INSTITUTION STAFFING REQUEST.
PROVIDES THE REQUIRED PEACE
OFFICER STAFFING COMPLEMENT
FRUIT SELECT ADULT INSTITUTIONS
FOR THE SECURITY COVERAGE NEEDED
FOR MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AREAS AS WELL AS
PROGRAMMING AREAS FOR THE INMATE
POPULATION.
THE STAFFING RESOURCES WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY KNOWN OR IDENTIFIED
IN PRIOR REVIEWS.
THEY ARE TIGHT TO OUR HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT WHERE AT THE TIME WE
LOOKED AT THE BLUEPRINT DESIGN
OF THE BUILDING. AND WERE NOT
AWARE THAT WE WOULD HAVE A NEED
FOR STAFFING RESOURCES BASED ON
THE BLUEPRINT VIEW AND WHAT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN BUILT.
HAS YIELDED A NEED FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL STAFFING RESOURCE IN
THIS AS THE INMATE POPULATION
WILL BE IN AREAS WE HAD NOT
ANTICIPATED. IN ADDITION THAT WE
HAD SOME AREAS WHERE PREVIOUSLY
IN REVIEWS WE WERE NOT
PROGRAMMING INMATES AND NOW WE
HAVE PROGRAMS FOR THE INMATES
THERE AND REQUIRE THE SECURITY
COVERAGE.
AS WELL AS OUR EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION THAT HAPPENS ON
THIRD WATCH
WE ARE PROVIDING THE STAFFING
RESOURCES TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
ON IN THE PROGRAMS WHEN STAFF
ARE REPURPOSE TO PERFORM AN
EMERGENCY TRANSPORT.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HAS
TODAY. DAILY COMMENTS FROM.
PART OF FINANCE.
BELIAU.
NO COMMENTS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM UP HERE.
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH READ SOURCES.
YOU'LL HAVE TO PARDON THE
MUSICAL CHAIRS BUT YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE SOME PEOPLE MAKING A
SECOND APPEARANCE STARTING WITH
MISTER CHAMBERS FROM OUR OFFICE
OF RESEARCH SO. WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
CAESAR'S OFFICE OF RESEARCH
REQUEST SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SIX
POSITIONS ON GOING STARTING IN
BUDGET YEAR.
CONSISTING OF ONE RESEARCH
PROGRAM SPECIALIST ONE RESEARCH
SPECIALIST ONE SENIOR
INFORMATION SYSTEM ANALYST.
TO A. GPAS AND ONE OFFICE
TECHNICIAN AND AGAIN I'M JOINED
BY MISTER CHAMBERS FROM OUR
OFFICE OF RESEARCH WHO CAN
PROVIDE JUST A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ON THE PROPOSAL.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH FUNCTIONS
AS THE DEPARTMENTS RESEARCH
CHARM AND SERVES AS A PRIMARY
DATA PROVIDER FOR INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL CD SEE OUR CLIENTS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE STATE HAS
UNDERGONE DRAMATIC CHANGE IN
PRISON REFORM IN MANDATE
POPULATION REDUCTION MEASURES.
THIS CHANGE HAS LED TO AN
INCREASE IN INTEREST AND DEMAND.
ACROSS THE BOARD IN ALL AREAS
FOR CORRESPONDING DATA.
WHILE THERE'S BEEN A NEAR SIXTY
PERCENT INCREASE IN A RECENT
YEARS FOR SPECIALIZED TYPE
REQUEST.
WHICH EQUATES TO APPROXIMATELY
FORTY PERCENT OF OUR OVERALL
WORKLOAD.
THERE HAS BEEN NO CORRESPONDING
INCREASE TO POSITION ALLOCATIONS
AND BUDGET.
THIS AUGMENTATION THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING WOULD ALLOW THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TOWARDS.
INCLUDING CRITICAL WORKLOAD IN
CLOSING THE GAPS.
FOR THAT PURPOSE WE HAVE
REQUESTED SIX PERMANENT.
P. WISE TO ADDRESS OUR ONGOING
WORKLOAD INCREASE.
THESE POSITIONS OUR RESEARCH
SPECIALIST GENERAL ANALYSTS AND
ONE NIGHT HE CLASSIFICATION.
THESE POSITIONS AGAIN A
REPRESENT AN ACROSS THE BOARD
NEED TO PROVIDE RESEARCH AND
ANALYTICS.
DATA COLLECTION GENERAL DATA
ANALYSIS PREPARATION AND QUALITY
REVIEW.
WELL OUR BCP NOTED.
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED REQUEST EACH
MONTH.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE ACTUAL
LAST FOR MONTHS IS AN INCREASE
TO EVEN THAT NUMBER NOW WE'RE
AVERAGING CLOSER TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY REQUEST?
FOR MONTHS FOR DATA. THIS PY
AUGMENTATION WILL ENABLE US TO
PROVIDE MORE EXPEDITIOUS RISK
MORE EXPEDITIOUS RESPONSE. AND
ALSO TO FURTHER DELVE INTO THAT
MEETING IN INTERRELATION OF THE
DATA WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DO AT THIS POINT.
I THINK MADAM CHAIR YOU HAD
ASKED EARLIER ABOUT. THE
INCREASE IN FELON POPULATION IN
WHY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS WOULD HELP US TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO IN A QUICKER MANNER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
FOR AND FINANCE ILIO.
YEAH ONE OF HERE.
OKAY THIS TO ITEM TO LIKE THE
OTHERS WILL BE HELD OVER PULLED
THE FUND ITEM NUMBER FOUR
CONSISTS. ROLE NONRACIAL PROGRAM
PORTIONS
POSITIONS AS HE'S.
FROM. THAT THAT WE WERE GOING TO
BE AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE AND
I THINK WE'RE ACHIEVING IT SO
FAR SO I HOPE I DIDN'T USE THAT
BY SAYING THAT BUT WE'RE GONNA
TRY AND STAY ON TRACK WITH THAT
SO LIKE A PLAN.
NEXT UP IS.
A PROPOSAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FOR TWO POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS FOR ARE DAVID DIVISION
OF ADULT FOR ALL OPERATIONS.
.
THESE ARE SUPPORT POSITIONS THAT
HAD BEEN ELIMINATED AND OUR
BLUEPRINT THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER.
.
AT THE TIME OF THE BLUEPRINT
THERE WAS.
ANTICIPATION THAT ARE POORLY
POPULATION BY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WAS GOING TO DECLINE TO ABOUT
TWENTY ABOUT TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND AND AS YOU'VE HEARD NOW
A COUPLE OF TIMES.
OUR ACTUAL BUDGET YEAR
PROJECTIONS ARE CLOSER TO FIFTY
THOUSAND SO OBVIOUSLY A MATERIAL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO
NUMBERS O WITH THAT IN MIND.
THE DEPARTMENT IS ASKING FOR
OTHERS TWENTY THREE POSITIONS
THAT ARE LAID OUT ON YOUR AGENDA
I'M JOINED BY.
DIRECTOR JERRY POWERS FROM OUR
DIVISION OF ADULT PEARL
OPERATIONS IS GONNA PROVIDE JUST
A LITTLE MORE CONTEXT FOR THE
PROPOSAL THEY WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MORNING MEMBERS IS
SAID JASON SAID JERRY POWER
STAFFORD DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME THIS MORNING I WILL BE
BRIEF.
.
JUST TO PUT IN CONTEXT AND I
APOLOGIZE SIR OF AN I'M SORRY
MISTER TING IS IN HERE TO TALK
ABOUT RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
WE HAVE.
AS JASON SAID WE WERE
ESSENTIALLY ZERO BASED ABOUT
BUDGETED DE UM FIVE YEARS AGO
SIX YEARS AGO.
TO A POPULATION ANTICIPATED
POPULATION SOMEWHERE AROUND
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND OR SO OUR
POPULATION CURRENTLY IS
SOMEWHERE FORTY SIX TO FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND GROWING TO FIFTY
THOUSAND SHORTLY.
AYE IN THAT TIME ARE ARE NO I'M
SWORN PERSONNEL ARE SUPPORT
SUPER SPUR SINGLE SERVICES THAT
ARE NON RATIOS POSITIONS HAVE
NOT GROWN WITH THE POPULATION
WHEREAS OUR OUR PAROLE AGENT
POSITIONS WHICH ARE RATIO WOULD.
TO THE PAROLE POPULATION HAVE
INCREASED INCREMENTALLY AS THE
POPULATION HAS INCREASED.
I'M JUST TO GIVE YOU A BENCHMARK
IDEA OF WHAT THAT WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE IS.
IN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN OUR
POPULATION FOR ALL POPULATION
WAS ABOUT FORTY SIX THOUSAND AND
WE HAD SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
NON RATIO SUPPORT POSITIONS IN
IN THAT APARTMENT.
OUR CURRENT POPULATION IS
SOMEWHERE AROUND FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND SO WHEN TALKING TRYING
TO GET AN EQUIVALENT NUMBER. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN NON SOME
NON RACIAL POSITIONS ARE SUPPORT
POSITIONS.
SO WERE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY POSITIONS BELOW WHERE THE
POPPY IF YOU COMPARE THOSE
POPULATIONS ARM.
TODAY SO BOMB.
THE JUSTIFICATION SIMPLY HAS
PASSED AS THE PAROLE POPULATION
GROWS AS WE AB PAROLE AGENTS
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT WORK THAT
GOES BEHIND THAT.
TO THE ALEJO'S.
.
SUGGESTION A RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE TURN ON RACIAL POSITIONS INTO
RATIO POSITIONS
CERTAINLY THAT IS THAT IS ONE
APPROACH TO TO TO TO THIS. AYE
IT ALMOST PUTS US ON AUTOPILOT
AS FAR AS BUDGETING AND AND
PERSONNEL GOES.
IT'S EASY TO DO WITH PAROLE
POSITIONS BECAUSE FOR EVERY
PAROLE  YOU CAN YOU CAN
DETERMINE HOW MANY YOU UP FOR
ALLEGIANCE YOU NEED.
BUT WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
VERY GOT MENU OF OF SUPPORT
POSITIONS TO DEAL WITH THINGS
LIKE WORKMEN'S COMP AND
BACKGROUNDS IN STAFF TRAINING IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO RATIO THOSE
KINDS OF POSITIONS
ADDITIONALLY AS THINGS CHANGE
REGULATIONS CHANGE LAWS CHANGE.
EVEN AUTOMATION COMES ON BOARD
SOME OF THOSE RATIOS BECOME.
UNNECESSARILY HIGH OR
UNNECESSARILY LOW.
IN THAT BECOMES PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE AND WE HAVE TO GO BACK
AND CONSTANTLY ADJUST THE RATIOS
OR IN MY EXPERIENCE OVER THIRTY
PLUS YEARS WHAT WE DO IS WE
START SWAPPING. I'LL GIVE YOU UP
I'LL GIVE UP TO OF THESE
POSITIONS IN THE RATIO TO GET
ONE OF THESE.
FOR INSTANCE AS WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY DID HIS IMPROVED FOR
MY PAROLE AGENTS.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY NEED PEOPLE
TO MANUALLY ENTER CASE NOTES AND
TO FILE THINGS BECAUSE NOW IT'S
ELECTRONIC.
THE BACKSIDE OF THAT IS WE NEED
MORE IT SUPPORT.
SO WHAT WHAT WE IF WE HAD RATIO
THOSE POSITIONS FIVE YEARS AGO
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT TODAY.
SO BY US COMING TO YOU AND
ASKING FOR RATIO DIFFER
NONRACIAL POSITIONS WE REALLY
YOU'RE JUST TO FIND THOSE
POSITIONS BASED ON THE ACTUAL
WORKLOAD THAT WE SEE VERSUS SORT
OF ON AUTOPILOT SORT OF
BUDGETING.
AND STAFF ALLOCATIONS
SO I THOUGHT I'D CERTAINLY BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
ANY COMMENTS ROOM FINANCE
BELIAU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JONATHAN PETERSON AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AS THE DEPARTMENT INDICATED THEY
HAVE THEIR DIRECT SUPERVISION
POSITIONS WHICH THEY ANNUALLY
ADJUST IN THE BUDGET DEPENDING
ON.
THE SIZE AND COMPOSITION OF THE
PROBABLY POPULATION
AND THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT
POSITIONS WHICH THEY HAVE
TYPICALLY REQUESTED ON AN AD HOC
BASIS.
SO WE RECOMMEND THE DEPARTMENT
UTILIZE A RATIO DRIVEN APPROACH
FOR THE SUPPORT POSITIONS THAT
TAKES INTO. ACCOUNT THE SIZE AND
COMPOSITION OF THE PEARLY
POPULATION FOR BOTH DIRECT
SUPERVISION AND THE SUPPORT
POSITIONS.
AND RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CDS YARD
REPORTED BUDGET HEARINGS ON A
PLAN TO INCORPORATE THESE
SUPPORT POSITIONS INTO THE
ANNUAL ADJUSTMENT.
AN IMPENDING SUCH A REPORT AS
WELL AS THE UPDATED POPULATION
PROJECTIONS THAT COME WITH THE
MAY REVISION WE WITHHOLD
RECOMMENDATION ON THE. RIVER
PACIFIC NUMBER OF POSITIONS
REQUESTED BOTH ON THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION AND ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE.
AND WHILE IT IS CERTAINLY THE
CASE THAT THE SUPPORT POSITIONS
ARE NOT AS DIRECTLY TIED TO
SPECIFIC CASELOADS AS YOUR
DIRECT SUPERVISION PRO AGENTS.
THAT'S AN APARTMENT INDICATED
THEY STILL ARE DRIVEN BY CHANGES
IN THE PROPERLY POPULATION FOR
EXAMPLE PART OF THESE POSITIONS
IS TO ADDRESS THE TEMPORARY
INCREASE IN POPULATION THAT'S
EXPECTED AS A RESULT OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY
SEVEN.
I AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HOW DOES USE RATIOS
THAT DON'T ADJUST.
BASED ON SPECIFIC CASELOADS FOR
OTHER POSITIONS ONE EXAMPLE
WOULD BE FOR EVERY TWO THOUSAND
INMATES
THE DEPARTMENT OF IT GETS
ANOTHER DENTAL HYGIENIST.
SO THERE AREN'T RATIOS THAT
AREN'T ADD AS I AM I GUESS FLY
AYE AREN'T AS SMALL AS SAY A
TWENTY TO ONE RATIO WE USE FOR
OUR HIGH RISK SEX OFFENDER
PAROLEES.
AND THAT THE IN THE CASE OF THE
HUMAN RESOURCE ANALYSTS
AS YOU INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PRO AGENTS YOU DO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE YOU NEED TO
REQUEST ANALYSTS AND AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL THEY SAY
THEY WANT TO KEEP. THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS AT AROUND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY PER ANALYSTS SO THEY DO
HAVE AN EFFECT A RATIO BUILT IN
FOR THAT SO WERE ASKING FOR A
PLAN TO KIND OF. PUT THOSE INTO
THE ANNUAL ADJUSTMENT AND.
TO HELP.
ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES IN THE
POPULATION OVER TIME.
YOU COLLECTIONS APPEAR.
OKAY.
I HAD SAID THE QUESTION
CONCERNING THAT AND I THINK YOU
ANSWERED IT AND AND IN BOTH OF
YOUR COMMENTS WITH REGARDS TO
WHY WOULD YOU WANT A. OF WHY WE
MADE ONE OF RACIAL DRIVEN UP
POSITIONS VERSUS NON RACIAL.
DRIVEN POSITIONS AND SO LEFT FIT
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION.
.
YEAH THAT THAT ITEM ALSO WILL BE
HELD OVER AND SHOW. YOU ABOUT IT
TO ME REVISION ITEM NUMBER FIVE
REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
CREDITS.
PAUSING MOMENTARILY FOR MY NEW
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT TO JOIN ME
AT THE TABLE.
OKAY WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THIRTEEN MANAGEMENT SERVICE
TECHNICIAN POSITIONS ON GOING
STARTING IN BUDGET YEAR.
THESE MST IS WOULD BE PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR FACILITATING AND
TRACKING IN MAY PARTICIPATION IN
THOSE.
RACKS AS WE LIKE TO REFER TO
THEM.
I'M JOINED AGAIN BY MISS
BARRETTO FROM OUR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS WHO CAN
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION WILL ANSWER ANY.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
STAFF RESOURCES TO EXPAND OUR
REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
CREDIT PROGRAM BY INCREASING OUR
ENEMY ACTIVITY GROUPS.
RESULTS IN THE INMATE
POPULATION.
EARNING ADDITIONAL CREDITS.
WHICH ULTIMATELY RESULTS IN A
REDUCTION ON THEIR SENTENCE AND
TIME IN PRISON.
THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS PROVIDE
FOR CONSISTENT AND STABLE
WORKFORCE WHEN PROGRAMS ARE MOST
FREQUENTLY RUNNING WHICH
TYPICALLY IS ON THIRD WATCH ON
WEEKENDS.
THE POSITIONS WILL BE UTILIZED
AN THE INSTITUTIONS WITH THE
HIGHEST VOLUME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
TO PROVIDE THE ESSENTIAL. OF
SUPERVISION OF OUR VOLUNTEERS
AND TRACKING IN COORDINATION OF
ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS
IN ADDITION IT ALLOWS FOR
ADDITIONAL HOURS OF THE RACKS
PROGRAM. EARNINGS
I'D BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU ME HOW BEEN THE
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
BELIAU.
THE
APPEAR.
OKAY FUND THANK YOU THAT I AM TO
WILL BE HELD OVER GO TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX
FOLLOWING THIS OF THEIR ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON ONE
THROUGH SIX.
WE WILL HAVE YOUR COMMENTS AT
THAT TIME.
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING GRANTS.
OKAY.
WITH THE PROPOSAL RELATED TO
OUR INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING
GRANTS THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING SIX SORRY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FROM OUR INMATE
WELFARE FUND.
ONGOING STARTING IN BUDGET YEAR
TO SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF
THIS PROGRAM.
THAT WE STARTED JUST.
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AGO I
BELIEVE IT WAS.
.
ACTUALLY.
IT'S IN MY NOTES IF I'D READ MY
NOTES I KNOW THAT SO WE STAB US
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THROUGH AN INVESTMENT.
OF BOTH IWF AND OUR R. F.
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION FUND MONIES
BACK THEN SO. ARE THE LATEST
INVESTMENT IS SITTING AT ABOUT
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND I SCHEDULED TO BE REDUCED TO
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET
YEAR. AND THEN TO GO TO ZERO AND
TWENTY TWENTY THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD ESTABLISHED A FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM INMATE
WELFARE FUND FOR THE SUPPORT OF
THOSE GRANTS.
I'M JOINED BY RYAN SOUSA.
WHO IS OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITHIN OUR DIVISION OF REAL BILL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS? AYE MR
SUSE IS GOING TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
PROPOSAL AND THEN WE'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING. OF MY OWN HERE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY INSURANCE IS A AGAIN I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION
EVERY ABILITY TO PROGRAMS AYE
AYES JASON REFERENCE. DID THE
FUNDING IS ENDING TOWARDS THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS AND THAT THE
DIVISION IS GONE BACK AND LOOKED
AT HIM IN TOTAL AND THE POSITIVE
BUT ANECDOTAL INFORMATION AND
JUST.
THAT THAT'S.
THE RESEARCH HAS BEEN
SURROUNDING GIVING PROGRAMMING
AS A HOLISTIC FEEL TO THE
OFFENDER POPULATION SO. HERE WE
REQUESTED A CONTINUATION OF THIS
GRANT.
AND WE'VE MORE NARROW THE FOCUS
IN TERMS OF JUST
APPLYING GRANTS AYE DO THAT
WITH.
SIXTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
SPLIT HAS PROPOSED TO FOCUS ON
THOSE GRANTS THAT ARE.
BOTH ADHERING TO PROMISING
PRACTICES
ON AND I'LL GO THROUGH A KIND
OF.
.
THREE STEP ON ON AN OVERVIEW OF
HOW.
GRANTS OR EVEN TREATMENT
PROGRAMMING COULD BE APPLIED IN
GENERAL WE ALL HEAR THE TERM
EVIDENCE BASED.
THAT PRACTICE IS REALLY BASED ON
RIGOROUS RESEARCH THAT HAS
DEMONSTRATED PRACTICES THAT ARE
ACHIEVING THE OUTCOMES NECESSARY
A LOWER LEVEL TO DINE ON AND THE
AND THE WHERE WERE FOCUSING
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR GRANTS
IS PROMISING PRACTICES.
THOSE ARE NOT SIMILAR TO OUR
PROGRAMS AND STRATEGIES THAT
HAVE SOME SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
BUT HAVEN'T NECESSARILY BEEN
RIGOROUSLY RESEARCHED EVIDENCE
BASED SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
TAKING SOME ELEMENTS OF THOSE.
I'M AND FOCUS IT ON THE
CORRECTIONAL PROGRAM CHECKLIST
IN BOTH THE CRITERIA AND GRANT
APPLICATION THAT GOES AN AFFRONT
WE'VE BUILT IN KIND OF THOSE
CHECKS AND BALANCES AFFRONT TO
GET APPLICANTS. THAT HAVE THOSE
PROMISING PRACTICES KIND OF
BUILT INTO THE APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE RECEIVED AND
THEN SUBSEQUENTLY ALSO HOW WE
GREAT THOSE.
AND IN THE LATTER PORTION THE
SECONDARY AND FINAL TIER OF OUR
GRANTS ARE THE THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT THERE REALLY CAN'T
PRACTICE BASED GRANTS THOSE ARE.
USING COMMON PRINCIPLES AND
PRACTICES THAT ON MAY LEAD TO
PROMISING PRACTICES IN THE
FUTURE BUT REALLY JUST EVIDENCE
THAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE A
POSITIVE RESULT AND THAT STILL
ALLOWS TRUE INNOVATION IN OUR
GRANT PROGRAMS WHICH IS WHY WE
FEEL LIKE IT IS REALLY NECESSARY
REHABILITATION NOT EVERYONE
NEEDS THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF KEY
MEMBER REALLY GETS. A PLETHORA
OF.
TREATMENT AVAILABLE AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM AVAILABLE
TO THESE OFFENDERS DURING THE
ENTIRE COURSE AN INCARCERATION.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE PRACTICES.
IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
FINANCE.
WRITTEN RAIN APARTMENT FINANCED
THE HIGHLIGHT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO ESTABLISH AN
ONGOING AND SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE SUCCESSFUL GRANT
PROGRAM. AND REALLY BRINGING THE
COMMUNITIES INTO THE PRESIDENT
TO.
DUTIES INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
OKAY. ELLIOTT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHAN PETERSON
WHAT THE LA SHOW. UP AS A
DEPARTMENT INDICATED THEY'RE
FOCUSING THESE GRANTS AT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN THEY HAVE IN
THE PAST AND PART OF THAT IS TO
FOCUS ON PROGRAMS THAT HAVE.
BEEN ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE SOME
LEVEL OF.
EFFECTIVE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMMING STRATEGIES USING THE
CHECKLIST MENTION.
WE RECOMMEND RATHER THAN FOCUS
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE GRANT
FUNDING ON THOSE PROGRAMS USING
THIS CHECKLIST TO FOCUS ON ALL
HUNDRED PER FOCUS UP ALL ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FUNDING.
ON THOSE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN.
CONNECTED WITH EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
THIS WOULD RESULT IN THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON REDUCING
CRIME AND ALSO INCREASING.
THE BENEFITS TO THE STATE.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT.
FOCUS THEIR SCORING METHODOLOGY
WHICH IS STILL UNDER DEVELOPMENT
ON RECIDIVISM REDUCTION MEANING
THAT RECIDIVISM REDUCTION WOULD
BECOME THE TOP SCORING CRITERIA
AND THAT.
FRAMEWORK WHEN IT'S DEVELOPED
AND FINALLY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED
APARTMENT TO AWARD FUTURE
GRANTS.
BASED ON THE RESULTS THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT CURRENTLY RECEIVE
FUNDING ARE THAT WOULD RECEIVE
FUNDING UNDER THIS PROGRAM WOULD
CREATE AND IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT
EFFECTIVELY REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THIS FUNDING
MOVING FORWARD.
AND. WHILE THE REMAINING
PROGRAMS WHAT.
.
THE DEPARTMENT REFERRED TO AS
YOUR PRACTICE SPACE PROGRAMS
THEY COULD CONTINUE TO OPERATE.
IN THE PRISONS USING OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING WHICH IS%
HOW THEY WERE SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS WERE FUNDED IN THE PAST
AS THEY WERE REQUIRED TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT SUSTAINABILITY
IN PREVIOUS ROUNDS OF GRANT
FUNDING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FUND IS ONE OF
THE COMET YES JUST HEARD.
TO SPEAK GONDOLIERS POINTS WE
JUST WANNA KNOW THAT WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND.
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
IN THAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
GRANT PROGRAM IS TO TRULY ALLOW.
NONPROFITS TO COME IN AND BE
INNOVATIVE AND ALLOW COMMUNITIES
INTO THE PRESENCE WHO MAYBE
HAVEN'T DEMONSTRATED THOSE.
HAVEN'T REACHED THAT LEVEL OF
EVIDENCE BASED.
OKAY WECOME IT'S APPEAR.
OKAY.
A AYE I UNDERSTAND WHAT WILL BE
ATTEMPTING TO ACCOMPLISH IN I
THINK GO OUR FOCUS SHOULD ALWAYS
BEEN RECIDIVISM. AND THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK AND I KNOW
THE NEED FOR INNOVATION ONCE
YOU.
OBVIOUSLY. MAYBE BEING. HAVING A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM OUGHT TO BE
THERE BASIS BUT WHICH GIVING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR CONTINUING
THE FUNDING.
INNOVATION IS ALWAYS IMPORTANT
A BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE
STANDARDS THAT WE EVALUATE THOSE
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE
THE FUNDING FOR THEM SO WE DON'T
WANT TO LOSE SIGHT OF THAT I
THINK. BOTH OF YOU PROBABLY
GETTING AT THAT POINT AND SO I
THINK WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THAT
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT IT
CAN. DO THE COMPARISON A SIXTY
FIVE TO A HUNDRED PERCENT IN
TERMS OF HOW WE'VE FUND PROGRAMS
WHERE I THINK ANY CONTINUATION
OF FUNDING. HAS TO BE BASED ON
THE STANDARDS THAT THEY ACTUALLY
DO THE JOB THAT WE SAY THEY'RE
DOING OTHERWISE WE JUST GIVING
MONEY TO UP PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITY GROUPS. THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT AFFECT WHAT WE WANT
WHICH IS TO MAKE SURE THE FOLKS
ARE NOT COMING BACK AND TO GIVE
THEM THE SKILLS AND THE. SOFT
SKILLS AND HARD SKILLS AS WELL
TO.
STAY OUT CAME ANY QUESTIONS
ANYONE ELSE IN YOUR COMMENTS IS
I I WOULD JUST LIKE TO COMMENT
AYE WE A HUNDRED PERCENT AGREE
WITH YOU AND THE DIVISION. AND I
THINK WE AGREE WITH THE LA WAS
ASSESSMENT PART OF HOW WE
DEVELOPED ON THIS GRANT PROPOSAL
IS REALLY BEING ABLE TO DEVELOP
A SCORING CRITERIA BOTH.
IN THE END WHEN WE'RE AWARDING
GRANTS TO FOCUS ON THOSE EXACT
FACTORS AS MORE INFORMATION
COMES TO.
ITS FINALITY IN TERMS OF
RESEARCH SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD
PLAN.
AND WE HAVE ONE PERSON WHO'S
GOING TO ADDRESS THAT IS NOT
WHAT ITEM YOU ADDRESSING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON JIM
WHEN BURKE WITH THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WERE ALL FOR CLOSING PRISONS
WERE ALL FOR BRINGING.
ENDING OUR CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUT OF STATE
PRISONS.
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D SEE THE DAY
WHEN WE WOULD BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION WHEN I CAME HERE IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO THE POPULATION
WAS.
JUST UNDER A HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND.
IT'S ALSO VERY REFRESHING TO
HEAR ALL OF THE TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF REHABILITATION AND
I KNOW SOME REALLY GOOD WORK. IS
HAPPENING.
IN THE DEPARTMENT THERE.
WHEN WE DO TALK ABOUT CLOSING
PRISONS.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE OLDER PRISONS
WERE CONSTRUCTED.
NEAR URBAN AREAS
AND UNFORTUNATELY OF THOSE ARE
THE ONES THAT WE ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT CLOSING.
AND THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT
PRISONS IN URBAN AREAS OTHERS
MUCH BETTER ACCESS.
TWO ATTORNEYS TO FAMILY OF
VISITATION AND SO FORTH AND
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEERS.
PROGRAMS AT ONE TIME ONE OF
EVERY FOUR COMMUNITY VOLUNTEERS.
WAS A VOLUNTEER AT SAN QUENTIN.
PRISON AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
ONE OF THE ONES THAT WE ALSO
TALK ABOUT CLOSING SO. WHEN WE
DO TALK ABOUT CLOSING.
PRISONS WE HOPE IT WILL KEEP
REHABILITATION
AND MINE AND THE IMPORTANCE A
GEOGRAPHICAL PROXIMITY TO. TO
URBAN AREAS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OF.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS THE
INMATE PAY.
AND WE'LL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS
AFTER SEVEN LEVEL ALSO HAVE TO
EIGHT AND AFTER NINE. INMATE
PAY.
OKAY.
WITH MAY PAY.
.
SO.
SEE SEE OURS DIVISION ADULT
INSTITUTIONS IS REQUESTING ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING STARTING IN BUDGET YEAR TO
INCREASE AND MADE PAY RATES FOR
OUR PLANT OPERATIONS POSITION
SPECIFICALLY.
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS IS DESIGNED
TO INCREASE THOSE RATES TO A
LEVEL CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
ALREADY. A PRESENT FOR OUR
PRISON INDUSTRY AUTHORITY AND
OUR ENEMY WORD LABOR JOBS.
.
I'M JOINED AGAIN BY MISS
BARRETTO FROM OUR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS WHO CAN
PROVIDE LOW MORE INFORMATION AND
WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
INMATES EARN A CONSIDERABLY
HIGHER RATE WHEN USING THEIR
SKILLS WHILE PERFORMING THE
DUTIES AND I W. L. PROJECTS AND
MEET BOARD LABOR OR PRISON
INDUSTRY AUTHORITY JOBS.
IN THE PRESENCE AND MEET SUPPORT
SERVICE POSITIONS THE JOBS THAT
ARE DONE IN THE INSTITUTION BY
THE INMATES.
ARE ALLOCATED DIFFERENT PAY
RATES
PAID RATES.
INMATES WITH SKILL SETS FOR
PLANT OPERATIONS TO HELP
MAINTAIN THE FACILITY CAN ACCEPT
A LESS STRENUOUS JOB.
FOR THE SAME RATE OF PAY INSIDE
THE INSTITUTION IT COULD BE THAT
THEY ACCEPT A COOK POSITION OR
CLERK POSITION FOR EXAMPLE.
BY INCREASING THE PAY FOR PLAN
OPS POSITIONS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION FOR INMATES IT WILL
ENCOURAGE INMATES TO USE THEIR
TRADE SKILLS. WHILE BEING
EMPLOYED WITHIN THE INSTITUTION
THIS BENEFITS THE INSTITUTION
MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS THE
INMATE.
IN ADDITION WHEN THE INMATE
TAKES THOSE JOBS IN THE
INSTITUTION FOR PLAN OPS WHEN A
POSITION COMES OPEN WITH IWL OR
P. I A. THERE ACTIVELY USING
THEIR SKILL AND THEY MAKE THE
TRANSITION TO THOSE UP POSITIONS
THAT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS.
WHEN INMATES GO TO P. AYE IN IWL
THEY DO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS ASIDE FROM PAY
INCLUDING CERTIFICATES.
CREDIT EARNINGS.
SO WE DO INTEND TO SEE INMATES
PARTICIPATING IN THOSE PROGRAMS
WE DON'T BELIEVE WE WILL DRAW
AWAY FROM THOSE PROGRAMS BECAUSE
OF THOSE ADDED INCENTIVES.
WHEN AN ENEMY COMPLETE TONIGHT
W. ALL PROJECT THOSE TYPICALLY
ARE OR SHORT TERM. THEIR
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS WITHIN AND
EIGHT THEY RETURNED BACK TO THE
INSTITUTION FOR JOBS IN THE
INSTITUTION.
OFTEN FOR SIGNIFICANT PAY
REDUCTION THIS WOULD CORRECT
DOWN IN THOSE IN THOSE AREAS.
I ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
BEACON SEASONAL SPUR CIVIL
SERVICE CLASSIFICATIONS.
I READ THAT THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF CONCERNS FROM LA WHEN THAT
REGARDS I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE.
THE DEPARTMENT IS ACTIVELY
ADDRESSING VACANCIES AND PLAN OP
CIVIL SERVICE.
WE'VE DONE FOCUSED RECRUITMENTS
HIRING FAIRS AND A ROBUST SOCIAL
MEDIA PUSH.
JUST RECENTLY IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS
WE DID A ONE DAY RECRUITMENT AND
HIRING FAIR FOR SPECIFIC FOR
PLAN OPTS POSITIONS AT TO OVER
SOUTHERN INSTITUTIONS
CHUCKWALLA.
AN IRON WOULD.
WE'RE NINETY ONE APPLICANTS
ATTENDED.
WE'RE CONTINUING THOSE EFFORTS
WITH DOING ANOTHER LOCATION IN
LATE APRIL WITH PLANS FOR
ADDITIONAL LOCATIONS INTO THE
SUMMER.
HAVING VACANCIES ON OUR PLAN OP
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS DOES NOT
HINDER THE ABILITY FOR INMATES
TO PARTICIPATE AS WORKERS.
WE STILL HAVE PLENTY OF PLANT
OPERATIONS STAFF TO SUPERVISE
THOSE INMATES THAT TAKE THE
JOBS.
IN ADDITION WHEN WE HAVE
VACANCIES ARE PLAN OPS CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS.
TYPICALLY WE HAVE A LOT OF
OVERTIME TO COMPENSATE FOR THOSE
VACANCIES TO KEEP THE FACILITY
RUNNING INCLUDING POSITIONS THAT
REQUIRE TWENTY FOUR. HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK AS IT RELATES
TO STATIONARY ENGINEERS WITH OUR
WATER WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PROGRAMS.
WELL THE REGULATIONS DO NOT
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE MILESTONES
OR REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
CREDITS FOR SUPPORT SERVICE
POSITIONS THE AND MANY JOBS IN
THE PRISON.
WE DO PROVIDE THEM WITH PAYING
AND THE INMATES ALSO CAN
PARTICIPATE IN ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WHEN THEY'RE NOT AT
WORK.
BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HOW THAT
OF A.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
THIS PROPOSAL ALONG WITH OUR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROPOSAL THAT WILL GET TO NEXT.
IT'S DESIGNED TO TRAIN IN MADE
WORKFORCE THAT NOT ONLY CAN FILL
THESE CRITICAL POSITIONS BUT
ALSO THEIR EQUIPPED WITH SKILLS
THAT ARE EMPLOYABLE CON
RELEASED.
ON AS THEY PARTICIPATE IN OUR
CURRENT TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
MILESTONE COMPLETION CREDITS
JUST AS A WOULD BE ENOUGH AYE
WLUP AYE A TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND THEN UPON COMPLETION THEY
HAVE IN ME EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
.
THE IF THE PROPOSAL NEARLY SIX
TO CREATE PARITY BETWEEN THE
SIMILARLY SKILLED POSITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE INSTITUTION.
AND ALSO ALLEVIATE THE HIGH
VACANCY RATE OUR PLAN OPERATIONS
FACILITY MAINTENANCE POSITIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE FOOD ELLIOTT.
KILLING ON NEIL LA L.. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE THINK IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
IT WILL REDUCE VACANCIES AN
INMATE FACILITY MAINTENANCE
WORKER POSITIONS AND AND. THIS
IS FOR TWO REASONS FIRST.
AS THE ADMINISTRATION MENTIONED.
INMATES NPI AND IWL POSITIONS
ALREADY RECEIVE OTHER NON PAY
BENEFITS SETS SO DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT IT WOULD NECESSARILY BE
ABLE TO ATTRACT INMATES AWAY
FROM THOSE POSITIONS. SECOND
INMATES ENGAGED.
IN OTHER TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
BESIDES AND IWL.
ARE ALREADY THERE SIT GIVEN THAT
THERE'S A THIRTY PERCENT VACANCY
RATE IN CAL PA POSITIONS WHICH
CURRENTLY OFFER THE HIGHER WAGES
AND THEN ADDITIONAL NON PAY
BENEFITS. IT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT.
INCREASING THE WAGES IS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ATTRACT
OTHER INMATES WERE ENGAGED IN.
MANY OTHER ACTIVITIES WHILE
INCARCERATED INTO.
THESE HIGHER PAYING JOBS THAT
USED A SIMILAR SKILLSET ADDS
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES I'M
FOR THE PLANT. MATT MAINTENANCE
INMATE WORKERS.
HOWEVER IF THE PROPOSAL IS
EFFECTIVE IN ATTRACTING INMATES
INTO THOSE POSITIONS.
IT COULD HAVE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES DEPENDING ON WHERE
IT'S ATTRACTING INMATES FROM AND
WHAT THEY WOULD OTHERWISE BE
DOING WITH THEIR TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE A COULD INCREASE
CAPITAL OUTLAY COST TO THE
EXTENTIT ATTRACTS INMATES AWAY
FROM IWL PROJECTS REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO.
USE. NON INMATE LABOR AT A
HIGHER COST TO COMPLETE ITS
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
IT COULD INCREASE PURCHASING
COSTS FOR CDC OUR AND OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO THE EXTENT
IT. I REDUCES INMATE LABOR
AVAILABLE TO P. I A AND IN TURN
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF GOODS PA
IS ABLE TO PRODUCE WHICH IN TURN
REQUIRES WOULD MEAN THAT THE
STATE. WOULD POTENTIALLY BE
PURCHASING PRODUCTS AT HIGHER
COST FROM OTHER SUPPLIERS.
AND TO THE EXTENT IT ATTRACTS
INMATES AWAY FROM OTHER USES OF
THEIR TIME THAT ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM
RELATIVE TO WORKING IN A PLANT
OPERATIONS. POSITION IT COULD
INCREASE RECIDIVISM.
I AND THEN TO THE EXTENT THAT.
IT ATTRACTS INMATES FROM OTHER
USES OF THEIR TIME THAT.
WOULD RESULT IN THEM EARNING
MILESTONE CREDITS IT COULD
RESULT IN SOME INMATES SPENDING
MORE TIME IN PRISON WHICH IN
TURN WOULD HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR
STATE COSTS.
AND THEN.
FINALLY.
THE ADMINISTRATION.
HAS INDICATED THAT IT IT ALSO
HAS
FACE CHALLENGES IN RECRUITING
CIVIL SERVICE WORKERS FOR
MAINTENANCE.
.
POSITIONS.
HOWEVER SO AT THIS POINT IT'S
STILL UNCLEAR TO WHAT EXTENT THE
BACKLOG THAT IS SITE IS THAT THE
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG THAT CITED
AS THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM HERE.
IS
IT'S GOING TO BE ADDRESSED BY
THIS ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST GIVEN IT'S
UNCLEAR TO WHAT EXTENT THAT
BACKLOG IS DUE TO CIVIL SERVICE
VACANCIES OR.
INMATE WORKER VACANCIES.
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WITHHOLD ACTION AND DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT ON WHY
IT THINKS OPPOSE WAGING INCREASE
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE IN INCREASING
FACILITY MAINTENANCE AND AND
REDUCING FACILITY MAINTENANCE
WORKER VACANCIES. IN LIGHT OF
THE CONCERNS WE'VE EXPLAINED
HERE.
HOW IT PLANS TO MITIGATE
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT I I'M ALLUDED TO INCLUDING
INCREASED CAPITAL OUTLAY COSTS
READ REDUCE RICK AT INCREASE
RECIDIVISM EXCITER?
THE NUMBER OF CIVIL SERVICE
VACANCY WORKER AT MAINTENANCE
WORKER VACANCIES.
HOW CDC ARE HAS SPENT THE
SAVINGS FROM THOSE VACANCIES AND
WHETHER COULD?
REDIRECT THOSE SAVINGS TO PAY
FOR THIS PROPOSED WAGE INCREASE
FOR INMATE WORKERS.
AND THEN WHAT STEPS IT IS
TAKING TO ADDRESS THOSE.
INMATE WORK THAT MAINTENANCE
WORKER VACANCIES WHICH AND WHICH
THEY HAVE ADDRESSED THAT WILL
CONSIDER TAKE BACKING CONSIDER.
ON.
AND BE BACK IN TOUCH.
THE COMMENTS
OF YES FINANCE.
THE TOUCH ON THOSE POINTS WE
DON'T SEE THESE.
THESE PLAN OPERATION POSITIONS
AS IN COMPETITION WITH PIAA WERE
IWL THE SEE THIS.
THIS PROPOSAL AS WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
THE TRAINING PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
PIAA AND IWL TO CREATE A TRAINED
WORKFORCE THEY CAN EARN
MILESTONE CREDITS WHILE THEY'RE
IN TRAINING. AND THEN WHEN THEY
GRADUATE UPON COMPLETION THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR EMPLOYMENT IN ALL
THESE DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
OUR INSTITUTIONS.
THESE ARE ALSO HIGHLY VALUED
SKILLS WITH COMMUNITY UPON
RELEASE SO.
ALSO.
BECAUSE I HAD A I WAS GONNA JUST
FOLLOW UP AND SAY THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO YOU KNOW TOUCH ON ANY
OTHER SPECIFIC CONCERNS MENTION
MY THAT LEO.
COMMENTS APPEAR.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE
ANYONE IN FAVOR.
PRO.
IN ONE AGAINST
THE PROPOSAL.
YES OKAY.
THANK YOU A JIM LINDBERGH FROM
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA.
WE JUST THINK THAT.
PAYING PEOPLE FOR THE WORK THEY
DO.
A.
THAT INCREASING THEIR PAY.
IS JUST THE RIGHT THING TO DO
JUST ON ITS ON ITS OWN
STANDALONE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU
OKAY.
WITH THAT ITEMS BEING HELD OVER
ONE TOLL ONE OTHER COMMENT YES.
A GOOD MORNING I MY NAME IS
EMILY HARRIS I'M WITH ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND TO
FOLLOW ON. WHAT JIM WAS SAYING?
LOOKING AT THE PAYSCALE FOR
PEOPLE IN PRISON YOU KNOW FOLKS
ARE MAKING VERY LITTLE MONEY.
AND WE REALLY ENCOURAGE THAT
WERE. RESOURCING FOLKS SO THAT
THEY CAN BE PAYING FOR
RESTITUTION SUPPORTING THEIR
FAMILIES SAVING FOR WHEN THEY'RE
COMING HOME AND SO THINKING
ABOUT TIME. HOW FAR YOU KNOW
FIFTY THREE CENTS AN HOUR IS
COMPARED TO WHAT FOLKS WE MAKING
THEM IF THEY WERE EARNING
MINIMUM WAGE IT REALLY
CONFLICTED STATE TO CONSIDER
PAYING PEOPLE MORE ALL THAT
WORKING IN PRISON? THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY
MOVING THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN OVER.
THE GOING TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
WHICH IS CAREER TECH EDUCATION
EXPANSION AND EQUIPMENT.
FRESH.
OKAY WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS EIGHT POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
ONE POINT FIVE POSITIONS
INCLUDING THIRTEEN INSTRUCTORS
AND EIGHT CIOS.
IN HALF CIOS IN BUDGET YEAR.
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY.
ALL DESIGNED TO EXPAND OUR CT
EQUIPMENT AT THE
FACILITIES.
TO THIRTEEN NEW SITES AT TEN
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS.
THERE IS A COMPONENT OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT DEALS DIRECTLY
WITH EQUIPMENT REFRESH THAT YOU
MENTIONED.
WE DID RECEIVE TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR FOR
THIS EQUIPMENT REFRESH THAT WAS
AN ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE. THAT
AND I DETERMINED THAT THE
ONGOING NEED IS ABOUT FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS SO THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE THAT
WHOLE. AND I'M JOINED AGAIN BY
RIGHT SUSAN WHO IS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE RP HE'S GONNA
PROVIDE YOU A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION THAT WILL ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
AS I MISTER LOPEZ MENTIONED WE
BASICALLY.
N'T ALICE'S
OFFENDERS WITH A MODERATE TO
HIGH NEED A FOR EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES AND LOOKED AT THAT IN
THE FIRST SCOPE OF THIS.
DISPERSED PART OF THIS BE CP
AND REQUESTED ON BASED ON THAT
ANALYSIS THIRTEEN ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS ACROSS TEN DIFFERENT
SITES.
AND ASSOCIATE THE APPROPRIATE
CUSTODY.
.
WITH THAT.
THE GOAL OF THIS WAS IN PART TO
START PUTTING THESE ON. CAREER
TECHNICAL EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS
AND INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE OFTEN
LACKING OR HAVE MINIMAL PROGRAMS
ARE READY SO.
WE FOCUSED OUR NEED THEIR. NON
AND LOOKED AT THE PROGRAM AND
TOTAL SO THIS PROPOSAL REALLY
ROUNDS OUT DRP.
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
FEEL CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
NEEDS.
AT THIS FIVE TIME BASED ON THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE RECEIVING.
THE SECONDARY PIECE OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS THE EQUIPMENT
REFRESHED HISTORICALLY THE
DIVISION HAS HAD TO INTERNALLY
REDIRECT FUNDING TO SUPPORT ON
ANY EQUIPMENT REFRESHED NEEDED
IN ALL THREE HUNDRED AND.
CURRENTLY THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THERE WAS LAST YEAR AS MISTER
LOPEZ MENTIONED SOME FUNDING
THAT WENT TOWARD THAT REFRESH
AND THIS.
ROUNDS OUT AGAIN THAT REFRESH
COMPONENT ME THAT PART OF THE
REASON THAT WE'RE REQUESTING
THIS PROPOSAL AND WHY IT'S SO
CRITICAL THIS YEAR IS WE HAVE
DONE.
A REALLY GOOD JOB FILLING
VACANCIES IN OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM I'M
AND I THINK THAT'S OUTLINED IN
THE BCP AS WELL. BUT THAT
ELIMINATES THE SAVINGS WE HAVE
IN FUTURE YEARS SO THIS IS AYE
AYE YEAR WHERE THIS REQUEST
BECOMES VERY CRITICAL FOR US. IN
BOTH BEING ABLE TO REFRESH
EQUIPMENT.
ACROSS THE STATE THAT SO THAT.
OFFENDERS ARE GETTING THE
CAREER TECHNICAL PROGRAMMING
THAT IS.
BOTH APPROPRIATE AND RELEVANT
AS THEY LEAVE TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND.
THAT ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE
FILLING OUR VACANCY SO THAT
WE'RE NOT IMPACTS ARE HAVING TO
HOLD VACANCIES TO REFRESH US.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
BELIAU.
WE DID NOT RAISE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY ECONOMISTS APPEAR.
KATIE COMES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY VERY NICE THAT BRINGS US
DOWN TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
THE DEPARTMENT.
OUR ENTERPRISE INFORMATION
SERVICES OFFICE THAT REQUEST
THIRTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS I'M ONE TIME FINDING.
IN BUDGET YEAR TO REPLACE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO SYSTEM FOR
STRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT AT NINE
ADULT INSTITUTIONS TO JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND A FIRE CAMPS AND
TO ADD INTEROPERABLE WITH THE.
TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
TRANSPORTATION UNIT.
THESE PURCHASES AND UPGRADES
WILL ALLOW DEPARTMENT AS IS
MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA. TO BE
FULLY COMPLIANT WITH.
TWO WAY COMMUNICATION STANDARDS
FOR ALL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
AND FIRST RESPONDERS. I'M JOINED
FOR THIS ISSUE BY DIRECTOR RUSS
NICHOLS OF OUR AND PRESENT MISH
SYSTEMS
DIVISION.
IS GOING PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ON THE MORE ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
ACCORDING DUCT WEBER MEMBERS.
THE RADIO SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
IS ONE FOUNDATIONAL TOOLS IN OUR
OUR PRISONS WITH HIS DAILY
ACTIVITIES OF MOVING OFFENDERS
TWO DINING HALLS TO EDUCATION
PROGRAMS VISITATION.
THE COMMUNICATION AND
MANAGEMENT OF THAT PROCESS.
HANDS ON THOSE RADIO SYSTEMS.
IN THE EVENT OF ANY SORT OF
UNPLANNED EVENT WHETHER THAT'S A
A MEDICAL EMERGENCY A FIGHT FIRE
ANYTHING ALONG THOSE LINES IT'S
AN EVEN MORE IMPORTANT CRITICAL
TOOL IN MANAGING THE RESPONSE TO
THAT.
SITUATION AND TO HAVING SOME
SORT TACTICAL CONTROL AND
ABILITY TO MANAGE THE
INSTITUTION IN GENERAL.
THE SITES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RADIO SYSTEMS AT THE
NINE PRISONS.
IN PARTICULAR.
AND THE JUVENILES SITES IN THE
TRANSPORTATION UNITS MOST OF
THOSE WERE INSTALLED WHEN THE.
EXCUSE ME WHEN THE FACILITY WAS
CONSTRUCTED THEY'RE APPROACHING
THIRTY YEARS OLD NORMAL LIFESPAN
ON ONE OF THOSE RADIO SYSTEMS
ACCORDING TO THE MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY IS ABOUT TEN YEARS. SO
THEY ARE WELL BEYOND A USEFUL
LIFE CYCLE.
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THAT THAT
THE PARTS TO REPAIR THE SYSTEMS
TO MAINTAIN THEM. ARE VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT
IN FACT LAST YEAR IN THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS WE HAD TO
CATASTROPHIC.
SYSTEM FAILURES.
AND IN BOTH INSTANCES WE WERE
LITERALLY WORKING WITH A VENDOR
WORKING WITH.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO SCRAPE TOGETHER
PARTS CANNIBALIZED THEM FROM
OTHER SYSTEMS TO GET THE THE
SYSTEMS REPAIRED. AT ONE POINT
WE WERE LITERALLY LOOKING AT
EBAY TO SEE IF WE COULD FIND
PARTS FOR A CRITICAL PIECE OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE THE
INSTITUTIONS.
WHEN THE SYSTEMS FAIL. AND
INSTITUTIONS PUT IN A POSITION
OF MODIFIED PROGRAMMER LOCKDOWN
WHICH MEANS THE OFFENDERS DON'T
GET VISITATION THEY DON'T GET
PROGRAMS.
IT SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS ALL OF
THE PROCESSES AT A PRISON THAT'S
A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SAFETY AND
STAFF AN OFFENDER SAFETY ISSUE.
AND AND IN GENERAL JUST
INHIBITS EVERYTHING OR TRYING TO
TO.
DO WITHIN THE INSTITUTION.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT.
THE COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
BELIAU.
OKAY I DON'T THINK WE ANY
COMMENTS APPEAR. ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE AUDIENCE ON ITEM NUMBER
NINE RADIO COMMUNICATIONS.
SEEMS FAIRLY CLEAR FAIRLY SIMPLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT BRINGS
US MASS ITEM TEN AND ELEVEN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THOSE TWO
ITEMS AND THEN WE WILL.
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS IF ANYONE
HAS ANY AYE AYE COMMENTS ON
THOSE ONE IS THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE THE ACADEMY. I
THINK WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATION ALREADY ABOUT THAT
WILL GIVE THEM REPORT YES.
OKAY.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN INVOLVES THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
ACADEMY PROPOSAL.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE.
TO RUN.
ONE ACADEMY OF YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS AND
YOUTH CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
INSISTING OF FORTY CADETS TOTAL.
I'M JOINED BY STACY LOPEZ WHO
IS OUR ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF OUR
PEACE OFFICER SELECTION EMPLOYEE
DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH OVERSEES THE ACADEMY AND
TO ADD TO HER LEFT I AM ALSO
JOINED BY DIRECTOR CHUCK SUPPLE
WHO IS OUR DIRECTOR DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE.
I WANNA START WITH MISS LOPEZ
AND THAT THEY WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING OTHER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN I'M
STACY LOCUS I'M THIS ISSUE
DIRECTOR FOR THE PEACE OFFICER
SELECTION AND EMPLOYEE
DEVELOPMENT. WITH OVERSIGHT OF
THE BASIC CORRECTIONAL JUVENILE
ACADEMY WE'VE BEEN RUNNING
ACADEMIES FOR THE JUVENILE.
A JUSTICE FOR THE LAST.
THREE YEARS
I WERE REQUESTING TO EXTEND OUR
FUNDING FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS
TO RUN FORTY CADETS THROUGH NEXT
NEXT BUDGET YEAR AND THEN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR FORTY CADETS SO
TOTAL OF EIGHTY OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
THIS IS A SMALL KEEP UP WITH OUR
ATTRITION AND.
ALLOW STAFF WHO ARE RETIRING OR
SEPARATING WILL BE ABLE TO
REPLACE THEM WITHOUT HAVING
VACANCIES
WITHIN THE JUVENILE TO CATCH UP
JUVENILE FACILITIES.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE OKAY
ECONOMISTS WHO FINANCE.
BELIAU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JR SORT OF
WORK LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SUITE IN RAISING CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY.
.
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE ALREADY OVER
THOUSAND STAFF MEMBERS AND ONLY
SIX HUNDRED. OF PROCESS SIX
HUNDRED STUDENTS OR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND AND YOU WILL JUSTICE.
AND WE NEED TO RUN ANOTHER
ACADEMY TO GET FORTY MORE
PEOPLE.
.
WELL IT I MEAN WHAT IS THE
RATIONALE FOR THAT I MEAN WHAT
WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH THE
ADDITIONAL STAFFING.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS THE ACADEMY.
LIZZY PARA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
JUST TO CLARIFY WE DO HAVE THAT
MANY STAFF BEING.
AUTHORIZED IN THIS BUDGET AND
THIS PROPOSAL IS LOOKING TO FILL
THOSE POSITIONS WITH PEOPLE SO.
WE'RE NOT REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS IN THIS PROPOSAL WERE
SIMPLY REQUESTING FUNDING TO RUN
CADETS THROUGH THE ACADEMY AND
THEN FILL THE VACANCIES THAT WE
HAVE.
THE FORTY POSITION NEED IS A
CONSISTENT WITH THE METHODOLOGY
WE'VE USED ON THE ADULT SIDE FOR
YEARS NOW.
WE DO OOK AT VACANCIES AT A
POINT IN TIME WE LOOK AT
PROJECTED GRADUATES FOR THOSE
ACADEMIES THAT ARE SCHEDULED
FREE NOW IN JULY AND THIS CASE.
AND WE ALSO LOOK AT THE AVERAGE
ATTRITION NUMBERS OVER TYPICALLY
AN EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD TO GET
AN IDEA OF WHAT TO EXPECT IN THE
WAY IT DEPARTURES.
ANY COMMENT FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
TAKE THE NEXT.
.
THE LAST ITEM WHICH IS THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
REFORM JUNE JUSTICE REFORM.
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN OKAY.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FIVE POINT SIX POSITIONS IN
BUDGET YEAR. GROWING TO SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
FIFTY ONE POSITIONS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY. AND THEN SETTLING AT
NINE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT
POSITIONS ONGOING STARTING IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WITH THESE RESOURCES AT THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES TO RAISE THE
AGE OF JURISDICTION PRETTY JJ
FROM TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
FIVE.
AND WE ALSO PROPOSED TO
ESTABLISH A PILOT YOUTH ADULT
PROGRAM.
WHERE BY SEVENTY SIX YOUTH
OFFENDERS WILL BE HOUSED AT THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
WHERE THEY? OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
BEEN HOUSE WITHIN OUR ADULT
INSTITUTIONS
AND WE TALKED ALL BUT ABOUT THAT
THIS MORNING WITH THE SECRETARY.
I'M JOINED FOR THIS ISSUE I'M BY
DIRECTOR CHECK SUPPLE FROM OUR
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
DIRECTOR SELLS GOING TO PROVIDE
A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
MUCH BETTER CHAIRMAN AND.
FULL COMMITTEE MEMBERS LITTLE
BUT A CONTEXT WITH REGARD TO THE
PROPOSAL.
TAKING A LOOK AT THE.
OF ALL VAIN RESEARCH WITH REGARD
TWO ADOLESCENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND RECOGNIZING THAT.
YOUNG ADULTS BRAIN IS NOT YOU
KNOW REALLY FULLY DEVELOP THINGS
SPECIFICALLY THAT AREA THAT.
ARE THOSE ADULT FUNCTIONS IN
THE PREFRONTAL CORTEX UNTIL.
AROUND THE AGE TWENTY FIVE.
TOOK A LOOK AT.
THE AGED JURISDICTION.
WITH REGARD TO THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT HE YOUTH.
CAN STAY IN DJJ AND AFTER
HEARING SOME CONCERNS WITH
REGARD TO THE TRANSFER PROCESS.
IN THE PROP FIFTY SEVEN RELATED
HEARINGS THAT THE AGE OF
JURISDICTION AS CURRENTLY SET AT
TWENTY THREE.
DOES NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH TIME
FOR.
OLDER YOUNG ADULTS SO TO SPEAK
COMING INTO THE TRANSFER
HEARINGS TO BE ABLE TO MEET THAT
FACTOR WITH REGARD TO.
TIME TO BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
REHABILITATION IF THEY'RE
AMENABLE TO IT.
AND THAT IF WE WERE TO RAISE THE
AGE OF JURISDICTION BACK TO THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE. THAT WE
WOULD SEE A GREATER NUMBER OF
YOUNG ADULTS ADJUDICATED TO DJJ
RATHER THAN CONVICTED. AS ADULTS
AND HAVING TO GO TO ADULT
PRISON.
AND CONTINUING WITH THAT LINE OF
REASONING IN THAT.
THERE ARE A FEW THE CURRENT
PRACTICES IS THAT YOUNG ADULTS
WHO DO END UP CONVICTED.
AS ADULTS USE JUVENILES
CONVICTED AS ADULTS.
COME TO DJJ AND IF THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR TERM.
ADULT TERM PRIOR TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE WE'RE REQUIRED BY LAW
TO TRANSFER THEM OVER TO THE
ADULT SIDE TO COMPLETE THEIR
TERM.
AND WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING IS
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO KEEP YEARS
WHO ARE ABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR
TERM. PRIOR TO TURNING TO THE
EIGHT TO TWENTY FIVE.
DEPENDENT UPON THE JURORS GOING
BACK TO TWENTY FIVE.
IF THEY'RE ABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR ADULT TERM PRIOR TO
TURNING THE TWENTY FIVE THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO STAY. IN
DJJ AND BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM
AND RATHER THAN GOING OVER TO
THE ADULT SIDE.
THEN FINALLY CONTINUE WITHOUT
LINE OF REASONING THE THOUGHT
WAS THAT PERHAPS THERE'S A
POPULATION OF YOUNG ADULTS WHO
WERE CONVICTED BETWEEN THE AGES
OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONE. WHO
ALSO COULD COMPLETE THEIR TERM
PRIOR TO TURNING THE AGED TWENTY
FIVE WHO COULD BENEFIT FROM
COMING TO DJ J. RATHER THAN
HAVING TO GO TO? ADULT PRISON.
AND THOSE ARE THE THREE PROPOSAL
SO TO SPEAK FOR AYE IN THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THEM.
VETERAN KATE CONTAINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ANYONE FROM FINANCE.
THOMAS BELIAU.
DID YOU START WORK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ON OVERALL WE
FIND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED CHANGES PROMISING
HOWEVER AS I WILL DISCUSS IN
GREATER DETAIL WE DO RECOMMEND
MODIFYING THEM TO ADDRESS SOME.
POTENTIALLY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES APPROVING THAT
CHANGES ON ONLY A LIMITED TERM
BASIS. AND DIRECTING DE GJ TO
CONDUCT SOME SPECIFIC
EVALUATIONS.
FIRST WE FIND THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO INCREASE DE JJ'S AGE
OF JURISDICTION TO.
TWENTY FIVE PROMISING AS IT
WOULD LIKELY REDUCE THE NUMBER
ADULT COURT THIS IS BECAUSE WHEN
JUDGES ARE CONDUCTING TRANSFER
HEARINGS ONE OF THE THINGS THEY
CONSIDER IN DECIDING WHETHER
TRANSFER YOUTH IS THE AMOUNT OF
TIME DJJ HAS TO REHABILITATE
THESE YOU.
ARM IN ADDITION RESEARCH DOES
SHOW THAT YOUTHS WHO REMAIN IN
JUVENILE COURT RATHER THAN BEING
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT
GENERALLY HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES.
MOREOVER DESPITE THE FACT THAT
IT ROUGHLY EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR PER YEAR DJJ IS
QUITE A BIT MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
THE ADULT SIDE WHICH COSTS ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND PER INMATE PER
YEAR HOUSED IN A CONTRACT BAD.
JUVENILE COURT TERMS ARE
ACTUALLY SHORT ENOUGH THAT IN
CERTAIN CASES THEY CAN BE LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN COMMITTING AN
ADULT TO A LONGER A DART.
COMMITTING A YOU TO A LONGER
ADULT SENTENCE.
FOR EXAMPLE JUVENILE COURT USE
RELEASE FROM DJJ IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SPEND AN AVERAGE OF
AROUND THREE YEARS IN DJJ. WHILE
ADULT COURT USE WHO'D BEEN SENT
DIRECTLY TO THE STATE PRISON
SPACE SYSTEM SPEND ABOUT NINE
YEARS IN PRISON.
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
SOME YOUTH WHO ARE CURRENTLY
RELEASED AT TWENTY THREE NOW
WOULD END UP STAYING OUT FOR AS
MUCH AS TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS. WE
VIEW THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT SIMPLY%
KEEPING YOUTH AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME THAN AVERAGE. DOESN'T
INCREASE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAMS.
BUT WE FIND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TO PROPOSALS TO
ALLOW ADULT COURT USED TO STAY
IN BJJ UP TO THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE TO BE PROMISING. AS
RESEARCH DONE IN CALIFORNIA DID
SH SUGGESTS THAT YOUTH WHO ARE
KEPT IN DJJ RATHER THAN SENT TO
ADULT PRISON SHE ARM HAD BETTER
OUTCOMES.
HOWEVER BECAUSE DJJ AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IS QUITE A BIT
MORE EXPENSIVE IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHETHER THIS IS A COST EFFECTIVE
WAY OF REHABILITATING THESE YOU.
AREN'T WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
EVALUATION OF HOW EFFECTIVE DO
YOU JJ'S PROGRAMS ARE. FOR
EXAMPLE WELL DJJ GENERALLY DOES
BASE ITS REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
ON MODELS THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO BE EFFECTIVE ELSEWHERE. ARM
IT IS NOT CURRENTLY ASSESSING
ITS PROGRAMS WITH TOOLS KNOWN AS
FIDELITY ASSESSMENTS TO ASSESS
WHETHER THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING
BEST PRACTICES AS THEY ROLL
THOSE PROGRAMS OUT THOUGH THEY
WILL BEGIN DOING SO NEXT YEAR.
IN ADDITION DJJ IS NOT PLANNING
ON RELEASING AN OVERALL
EVALUATION OF THE A ACTUAL
EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS PROGRAMS
UNTIL THE END OF TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY.
FINALLY DESPITE OPERA POSING THE
YOUNG ADULT OFFENDER PROGRAM AS
A PILOT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT PROPOSING AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM'S COST
EFFECTIVENESS. AND IS PROPOSING
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
THESE FACTORS MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS
WHETHER DJJ WILL BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY REHABILITATE THE
YOUTH. THAT THEY WOULD BECOME
RESPONSIBLE FOR AS A RESULT THE
PROPOSAL.
OUGHT TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
WE HAVE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
FIRST WE RECOMMEND ONLY
APPROVING THESE POLICY CHANGES
FOR A FIXED PERIOD OF TIME SUCH
AS SEVEN YEARS AS THIS WOULD
ALLOW THESE CHANGES TO GOING TO
A FACT. AND PROVIDE TIME FOR
ABOUT YOU ASIAN.
SECOND WE RECOMMEND THAT DJJ
REQUIRE EXCUSE ME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED DJJ TO
CONTRACT FOR AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF THE YOUNG ADULT
OFFENDER PROGRAM. AND DIRECT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY TEN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE NOTE THAT
THIS COULD POSSIBLY COST AROUND
A COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN THE MEANTIME WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE'S WAITING FOR THE
OUTCOME OF THIS VALUATION WE'D
RECOMMEND DIRECTING DJJ TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
OUTCOME OF ITS FIDELITY
ASSESSMENTS IN ITS OVERALL
PROGRAM EVALUATION.
FINALLY WE RECOMMEND MODIFYING
THE PROPOSED CHANGE TO DO JJ'S
AGE OF JURISDICTION.
BECAUSE IT COULD NEGATIVELY
AFFECT SOME YOUTH AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER SPECIFICALLY WE'D
RECOMMEND PROVIDING JUVENILE
COURT JUDGES WITH THE.
FLEXIBILITY WHEN THEY'RE
CONDUCTING OUR TRANSFER HEARINGS
TO.
ALLOW YOU TO STAY IN BJJ UPS THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE ONLY IN CASES
WHERE THE JUDGE DETERMINES THAT
NOT DOING SO WOULD NECESSITATE
TRANSFERRING THE YOUTH TO ADULT
COURT. WE THINK THAT THIS WOULD
PREVENT THESE YOUTH FROM GOING
TO ADULT COURT WITHOUT
UNNECESSARILY AFFECTING YOU
THROUGH OUR RD IN DJJ.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
ANY.
MANY QUESTIONS APPEAR YES.
I THINK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND JUST
TO FOLLOW UP A LITTLE BIT
DIRECTOR YOU KNOW I'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS ISSUE A LITTLE BIT
AND.
I THINK IT'S.
DEATHLY GOING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THERE WAS GOING TO BE IN THE
DETAILS OF OF HOW THIS WORKS.
AND ENSURING THAT WE'RE NOT.
TAKING OPPORTUNITY TO HOLD THESE
YOUTH LONGER THAN NECESSARY WAR.
INTERFERING WITH THE ABILITY FOR
THEM TO GO BACK TO THEIR
COUNTIES WHICH IS WHERE. THEY
ARE CLOSE TO THEIR FAMILY
FRIENDS AND AND.
THE STRUCTURE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO NEED WHEN THEY COME OUT.
THE THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THIS IS THE COST AND I THINK
THAT THIS PROVIDES US AN
OPPORTUNITY REALLY FILLED OUT
AND LOOK AT THE PROGRAMMING THAT
DJJ HAS BEEN DOING. BECAUSE IF
THE COST IS HIGHER KEEPING THEM
IN DJJ RATHER THAN GOING TO THE
DOE PRESIDENT THE REASON FOR
THAT. IS THE PROGRAMMING
REHABILITATION.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE THE
RATE OF RECIDIVISM THAN I'VE.
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF NOW THE SO
THE COMMITTEE I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT INVESTMENT THAT WE COULD
BE MAKING IN THOSE YOU.
SO LOOKING AT THE.
THE DETAILS OF OF HOW THIS WOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THE MAIN POINT WHICH I KNOW
IS THE MAIN POINT IS NOT.
SENDING YOU THOUGHT NECESSARILY
TO ADULT PRISONS WHERE THE
OUTCOMES ARE DRAMATICALLY
NEGATIVE THAT REALLY.
LOOKING TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
KIDS AND AND WHERE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR THEIR BEST
ATTRIBUTES SO GETTING REPORTS
BACK. VERY OUT HOW WE CAN BETTER
ANALYZE THIS PROGRAM THINK SHOW
SOME LIGHT IN.
ON WHAT'S WHAT'S BEING EFFECTIVE
OR NOT EFFECTIVE ONE THING I
WOULD ASK DOES AND THIS IS.
IT'S HIGH REALLY SELFISH THAT WE
GET SOME REPORTS BACK PRIOR TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
OTHER ALONG THE LINE SO THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE IT LOOK
AT IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM BUT
THAT WE'RE STILL HERE.
WHEN WE START TO GET SO REPORTS
BACK SO WE CAN WORK WITH DJJ ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THIS PROGRAM IS AS IT GETS
IMPLEMENTED. BUT.
I THINK THE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THERE ARE THE.
PROPER PROCEDURES IN PLACE
FOR TRULY FOR THE BENEFITS OF OF
THOSE KIDS PROGRAMMING
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION AND GETTING
THEM BACK INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE LIKE I KNOW
THAT'S PART OF YOUR GOALS AS
WELL. AND SO I I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD PROPOSAL BUT WE JUST NEED
TO WORK OUT A LITTLE BIT THE
DETAILS AND ENSURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING REPORTS BACK. TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN A TIMELY WAY.
TO BE ABLE TO ANALYZE THIS AND
AND HELP.
TO HELP ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAM
IS GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE IN.
AND SO WITH THE RESULTS THAT WE
NEED.
THANK YOU BUT I I AGREE THAT.
YOU KNOW. THAT THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY HAVING US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OF WOULDN'T THIS IS
MENTIONED AS A PILOT PROGRAM. OF
BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN IN DAY.
MOST PILOTS DO.
WE WE DID WANT TO KNOW THAT.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE.
THE RECOMMENDATION BY THE ILIO
TO HAVE LIMITED TERM FUNDING
HOWEVER.
.
YEAH AT THAT ADDING A SUNSET
DATE DOES PROVIDE SOME
OPERATIONAL ISSUES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT SUCH AS HIRING FOR
THE POSITIONS AND WE DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE BUDGET IS.
YOU KNOW AVAILABLE TO BE
REVISITED AND REVIEWED IN THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS IF THE
CHANGES NECESSARY IN THE FUTURE.
WE DO MENTION PILOT IN THE.
PROPOSAL I'M IN THE.
PLAN TO REVIEW THIS POPULATION
WHILE GOING THROUGH THE PROGRAM
TO SEE HOW BENEFICIAL IT IS TO
SEE IF IT CAN BE APPLIED TO
FUTURE POPULATIONS.
I'M KIND OF A STICKLER ABOUT
PILOTS THE AND LIKE TO BELIEVE
THEY REALLY ARE PILOTS AT THIS
AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE. WE LEARN
FROM IT BUT ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET OUT OF IT IF IT'S NOT
WORKING BECAUSE OF WHERE SOME
XIN IS THAT THESE THINGS WORK.
AND SOMETIMES THEY DO BUT.
HAVING BEEN AROUND.
BUREAUCRACIES FOR A LONG ENOUGH
TIMETO KNOW THAT.
YOU COULD UNDO YOU COULDN'T
BASICALLY UNDO THE GOOD THAT YOU
ANTICIPATE TO DO AN AUDIT OF
OTHERS THAT IT THERE SO FOR
INSTANCE IT SUPPOSEDLY IT'S NOT
GOING TO. IT'S GOING TO MAKE
MORE KIDS MAKES IT NOT TRIED AS
ADULTS BUT THE FLIP SIDE IS THAT
IT COULD ACTUALLY HAVE MORE
PEOPLE BEING TRIED AS ADULTS AND
WANTED TO AVOID THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM. BECAUSE THEY FIGURE THAT
MAY BE AN EASIER SYSTEM ON FOLKS
THAT THEY WANNA KEEP LONGER. AND
SO WE MAY FIND OUT IS THAT THERE
ARE MORE KIDS BEING TRIED IN THE
ADULT COURT. IN THE JUVENILE
COURT IF THAT HAPPENS THEN HOW
DO WE ASSESS AT HOW DO WE GET
OUT OF THIS.
IF IT HAS THE NEGATIVE AFFECT
IN AND I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
BUT I KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEALING WITH
INDIVIDUALS IN THE SYSTEM OFTEN
CALCULATE IN THEIR OWN MIND WHAT
THEY REALLY WANT TO SEE IN
RESULT. AND AS A RESULT CAN
BASICALLY UNDO THE PROCESS BY
HAVING MORE BY KIDS TRIED IN THE
ADULT SYSTEM VERSES IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM IF THEY FIGURE
THERE'S GONNA BE AN EASY WAY
OUT.
AND US I WOULD HATE THAT TO
HAPPEN TALL IN TERMS OF OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND OTHERS IN
TERMS OF MAKING THOSE DECISIONS.
THAT OFTEN HAPPENS TO CERTAIN
KIDS AND SO WE MAY DISCOVER THAT
WE BASICALLY UNDONE ALL THE GOOD
THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
DO.
IN THAT HAPPENED SOMEWHERE ELSE
IN THE SO
SO I THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR
US TO. BUILD IN SOME OF THOSE
SAFEGUARDS AND SOME OF THOSE OFF
RAMPS IN TERMS OF PROGRAMS OF SO
THAT WE'RE NOT LOCKED IN AND
THEN THAT'S DISCOVER OURSELVES.
OF FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD WITH
MAYBE FEW PEOPLE IN IN THE JUNE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND MORE OF THEM
IN THE ADULT SYSTEM A BECAUSE OF
WHAT FOLKS WANTED TO ACCOMPLISH
AND FELT WE WERE. TRYING TO BE
EASY ON CRIME HERE IN SACRAMENTO
SO.
I THINK A PILOT IS IS IMPORTANT
AND AND SOME ASSESSMENTS ALONG
THE WAY AS MY COLLEAGUES TALKS
ABOUT. A HAVING.
MORE ASSESSMENT MAKE SURE THAT
WE HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I THINK IF WE PROBABLY HAD DONE
MORE ASSESSMENTS IN THIS LAST
THIRTY YEARS OF INCARCERATION WE
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE STOPPED
SOMEONE A MADNESS THAT WE SAW. A
TAKING PLACE AS WE OUT WENT FROM
WHAT TWENTY FIVE MONTHS DID NOT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO TWENTY
NINE YEARS WHATEVER THE PEOPLE
BEING IMPRISONED WE PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE. STOPPED SOME OF THE
CRAZINESS THAT WE DID END UP
REASSESSED THE DIRECTION WE WERE
GOING BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
ANYONE. INTENDED TO INCREASE
THAT NUMBER VIEWS PEOPLE SPEND
IN PRISON APE THEY INTENDED TO
MAKE THE WORLD SAFER. ANDA AND
OBVIOUSLY WE DIDN'T LET ME
DESCRIBE THAT MUSCLE IN MAKE THE
WORLD SAFER BUT WE JUST MADE A
PRISON SYSTEM LARGER.
YET IF I MAY REALLY QUICK
AMATEUR NORTH PART IN A FINANCE.
I DO YOU JUST WANT TO REITERATE
OUR POINT THAT THE INTENT OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY JUST TO
ENCOURAGE JUVENILE COURTS. TO.
TRY THESE JUVENILES AS IN THE
JUVENILE COURT NOT SET HIM TO
THE DOOR QUIRK.
AND ALSO I WE DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT WHILE RAISING THE AGE
JURISDICTION TO TWENTY FIVE DOES
POTENTIALLY ALLOW FOR LINK
LONGER LENGTHS OF STAY.
THAT WAS NEVER OUR INTENT.
AND IN FACT OVER A TWO YEAR
PERIOD AT DJJ.
.
ONLY ABOUT ONE POINT NINE
PERCENT OF RELEASES ACTUALLY
STAYED UNTIL THEIR MAXIMUM YOU
KNOW CONFINEMENT TIME OF TWENTY
THREE SOARED TALKING EIGHT
PEOPLE OUT OF. FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR I THINK THAT WERE
RELEASED OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD
SO I JUST WANNA POINT OUT THEIR
X. AND KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT INCREASINGLY SO
STAY. AGAIN NEVER OUR INTENT AND
WORK WITH THE WORK THAT THE
BOARD A JUVENILE HEARINGS HAS
BEEN DOING AND FOCUSING ON
RELEASING JUVENILES WHEN THEY'RE
READY NOT WHEN THEY'RE MAKSIM
CONTENT CONFINEMENT TIME IS
THERE. YOU'LL THINK THIS
PRACTICE WILL BE CHANGING
ANYTIME SOON.
SO.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE
SAM OUR PROPOSAL OF RAISING IT
NOT THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH THE
INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL I THINK
ALL OF US AGREE THAT THAT IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD INTENT. AND WE KNOW
THAT EVERYBODY SITTING AT THESE
TABLES HAVE AS THEIR THEIR
INTENT WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE COSTLY MONITORING IT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THOSE WHEN IT
WHEN IT WHEN IT GOES LIVE AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE INTENT AND
HOPEFULLY WILL ACCOMPLISHING
THAT AND. AND AS A SAID MAKING
SOME ASSESSMENTS ALONG THE WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS STILL
ACCOMPLISHING.
BECAUSE.
WE WOULD NOT WANT TO HAVE THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF TO
OCCUR AS A RESULT OF SOME GOOD
WORK THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE
DOING THAT'S THAT'S ONLY
POSITION.
POINT UP IS ARE THE INCOMES FROM
THE AUDIENCE.
IT WILL HAVE.
TO COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE
CONCERNING THIS PROPOSAL. FROM.
I WAS MORE THAN TO SERVE OUT
THAT OKAY FOLKS LOOK AND SLOWLY.
YES YOU HAVE A MINUTE EACH OKAY.
GOOD MORNING WEARING WASHBURN
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND DG DAYS
BUDGET AND POPULATION. UMP DE
JJ'S OUTDATED PRISON LIKE
APPROACH IS FUNDAMENTALLY ILL
SUITED TO REHABILITATION
TREATMENT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND WE'RE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
IS THAT ADMITTED HISTORIC
DECLINES IN YOUTH CRIMEAND IN
THE POPULATION OF DJJ WE'RE
SEEING POSTAL TO INCREASE
AND EXPAND DJJ. WE'RE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED THAT THE
YOUNG ADULT PILOT WILL INCREASE
THE LIKELIHOOD.
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT CRIMINAL
COURT.
AND.
INCREASED LENGTH OF STAY BY
INCREASING EACH OF COMPLY THINK
THANK YOU.
HI I'M LUCY SALZEDO CARTER WITH
THE USE LAW CENTER.
WE BELIEVE IT'S PREMATURE TO
FUND THE YOUNG ADULT PROGRAM
INTEL RESEARCH IS DONE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE YOUNG ADULTS
NEEDS ACTUALLY ARE WHAT ARE
THEIR STRENGTHS WHAT OTHER
STRUGGLES.
WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMMING NEEDS
TO BE IN PLACE TO ADDRESS THESE
NEEDS?
AND AS ADVOCATES WE SUPPORT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE RESEARCH
BASED.
AND DATA DRIVEN.
AND WE SUPPORT SPECIAL
PROGRAMMING FOR YOUNG ADULTS WE
TO KNOW ABOUT THE RESEARCH AND
AND USE THAT AS A BASIS FOR WHAT
WE SUPPORT.
BUT WE DON'T REALLY FEEL THAT
THERE'S BEEN ENOUGH RESEARCH
DONE ON THIS PARTICULAR
POPULATION. AND HOW THEY CAN
BEST BE SERVED AND HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT DJJ BEING THE
PAST PROGRAM TO SERVE THEIR
NEEDS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ON GOOD MORNING DOCTOR WEBER
AND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS GEORGE VIA.
I AM ORIGINALLY FROM THE
SALINAS.
MY PROGRAM ASSISTANT FOR A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION CALLED
MOTIVATED INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP
FOR PUBLIC ADVANCEMENT.
HOMES WERE SEVENTY PERCENT
COMPRISES OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED.
THE CIVIC CLEANED IT DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
I'M CURRENTLY A UC DAVIS
STUDENT.
BUT BEFORE THAT AYE SPENDING
ACCUMULATION OF SEVENTY EIGHT
YEARS IN AND OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
AND IT WAS.
MANY FOR TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS
AND AND NON VIOLENT OFFENSES
SUCH AS.
THEY OWN.
POSITIVE TESTS OF MARIJUANA BUT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION HERE I FEEL THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE HOW DOESN'T HAVE A
SUCCESS RATE.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
APARTMENT OF VARIABILITY ATION
THAT THERE'S AYE SEVENTY FOUR
PERCENT USED TO BE A RE
ARRESTED.
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT RE CONVICTED
AND THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT GO
BACK.
STATE CUSTODY AS SOME YA MENTION
THAT INSTITUTION IS FAR FROM
HOME AND AND. AND OR THE YOUTH
THAT ARE. INCARCERATED MOSTLY
COME FROM LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
I CAN'T EVEN AFFORD TO PAY FOR
THE RESTITUTION AFTER GOING
WITH.
SO.
I ALSO HAVE A REPORTER FROM A
DOCTOR A PSYCHOLOGIST THAT YOU
KNOW TESTING ME FOR SEVERE PTSD
HYPER VIGILANT CORAZON I STILL
SUFFER FROM MAJOR DEPRESSION.
ADDED IT'S BECAUSE I FEEL THAT
THE INSTITUTION IT'S IT'S
SIMILAR TO PRESENT IT.
STAFF AT TIMES ARE NOT
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF US. AND.
ONE STAFF AYE ONE HIGHLIGHT IT
WHICH I KNOW HE STILL THERE IS
NAME IS. A MARTY GIANNINI WHO HE
TREATED US.
LIKE WE MATTER MORE THAN TO
BUILDING THAT HE WORKED WITH AND
THE CHECK HE RECEIVED EVERY DAY
AND HE WOULD WORK THIS OUT ALL
DAY HERE HELPLESS OUTSIDE ALL
DAY. AND WE WOULD COME BACK IT
WOULD BE RESTED IT WOULD BE
TIRED WOULD GO STRAIGHT TO BED
OR WE ARE OUR ENERGY WOULD BE
LOW SO THERE WOULDN'T BE.AND I
ALSO FEEL THAT THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF
A LEADERSHIP AND I'M AN ADULT.
IN IN THESE INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE
OF YOU YOU PUT ARE A USEFUL. IN
A ROOM FULL OF TRAUMA WILL OF
COURSE ARE GOING TO BE SKINNER
BREED NEGLECT IS GOING TO BRING
VIOLENCE IS GOING TO BRING.
VERBAL ABUSE.
AND I ALSO AGREE WITH SOME SOME
FOLKS HERE IT'S WAY TOO
EXPENSIVE FOR THAT YOU KNOW I
CAME I COME FROM. YOU KNOW.
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WE FOCUS
ON HILL IN OUR BODY AND AND DE
MASCULINE ARE MACHO ISM AND
BEING GENTLE WITH EACH OTHER I
THINK THAT SOME OF VERY QUICK
THAT'S MISSING YES MA'AM AND
AND.
I ALSO FEEL THERE SHOULD BE MORE
FOLKS LIKE ME WHO HAVE BEEN
THERE AND DONE THAT ARE DOING A
GOOD NOW ON OUR HEALING
OURSELVES TO GIVING BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HOT JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA.
WERE VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
BECAUSE ALL OF THE RESEARCH
SUGGESTS FACT COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS.
KEEPING YOUNGER PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WHERE THEY HAVE ACCESS TO?
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS AND FAMILY
SUPPORTS.
IT'S VITAL TO THEIR SUCCESSFUL
RE INTEGRATION INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND A LOT OF GOOD WORK HAS TAKEN
PLACE IN RECENT YEARS TO TRY AND
KEEP.
YOUNGER PEOPLE.
IN THE COMMUNITY AND.
THERE ARE ALREADY STRUCTURAL
INCENTIVES.
IN THE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM TO
TRANSFER PEOPLE.
TO THE STATE SYSTEM AND.
.
WE WERE VERY.
ENAMORED. WITH PROP FIFTY SEVEN
AND AND THE DECISION TO REQUIRE
JUDGES TO WEIGH IN ON THAT.
WERE VERY CONCERNED THAT.
JUDGES NOW UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
WILL FIND IT.
EASIER.
TO SEND.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
INTO THE STATE SYSTEM WHEN ALL
OF THE EVIDENCE SAYS THAT PAGE.
SHOULD REMAIN IN THE COMMUNITY
SO WERE OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY HARRIS OF
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER AND.
I ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE BEFORE ME
AND I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
ADDRESS THAT THE OPTIONS.
YOU KNOW THIS THAT COSTLY NESS
OF INCARCERATING YOUNG PEOPLE IN
DJJ THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND PER INDIVIDUAL JUST
IMAGINE WHAT WE COULD BE DOING
WITH THAT.
AND IN PARTICULAR CONCERNS BY
DJJ HOW FAR AWAY THE FACILITIES
ARE FROM PEOPLE'S HOMES KEEPING
PEOPLE CLOSER TO HOME AND AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE JIM HAD MENTIONED
THE CONCERN OF SENDING MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE THROUGH THE ADULT
SYSTEM EVEN IF IT IS THROUGH.
THE STATE.
THROUGH STATE AT DJJ WIND KEEP
PEOPLE LOCAL SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUDIENCE FOR THEIR COMMENTS.
AND WILL GET.
WILL LOOK AT THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE RAISED ABOUT THE PROGRAM
OBVIOUSLY MUCH MORE CLOSELY.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THOUGH
THAT OF THE.
.
THAT THEY AND I WAS LOOKING FOR
THE NUMBERS THAT I'M MISSING I
CAN'T PUT MY HAND OUT OF THAT
THE. JUVENILE POPULATION HAS HAS
DECREASED IMMENSELY.
AS A RESULT OF SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE DONE IN AND
TERMS OF PUTTING FOLKS BACK INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND EDU ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED NOW OF THE FOLKS IN
WHERE THERE WERE.
WHAT THREE FOUR THOUSAND BEFORE
OR SOMETHING?
HOW MANY?
ELEVEN THOUSAND AT SOME POINT SO
THAT MOST OF THE GET MOST OF THE
LOW LEVEL OFFENDERS ARE ARE AT
THE IN THE LOCAL AREAS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN THESE OF THE
MORE.
SERIOUS OFFENDERS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND SO WILL LOOK
AT THAT MORE CLOSELY BECAUSE I I
THINK SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE. BY THE PUBLIC OF
WITH REGARDS TO HAVING KIDS
CLOSER TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
HAD MAY HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN
THE IN THE IN THE AND BASICALLY
PUTTING FOLKS BACK INTO THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES BUT WE'LL LOOK
INTO THAT BECAUSE THAT IS
IMPORTANT. OF THAT'S THERE
CONCLUDES OUR MEETING TODAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING.
OF.
PRETTY PRECISE INCONSISTENT BANK
VIA A PUBLIC FOR ATTENDING.
AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU ALL AT THE NEXT
MEETING OF THIS MEETINGS DURING
ALL THESE ITEMS WILL BE HELD
OVER. ANOTHER WILL BE VOTED ON
AND SO AS A RESULT WE WILL VOTE
A MONTH ON THEM AT A LATER DATE
BUT THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH TAKE
CARE. OF.
TONI ATKINS COMIC JUSTICE ON
HANNAH.
YES MISS TONY HOW ARE YOU.
OKAY